[Music]
what's
good today we're back with another
episode and this time we got the
infamous Assad Ali who is he so Assad
Ali he's actually a friend of mine we
met in real life when uh he came to Ohio
State
University um to have a couple events
over there so uh those events went
really really well and uh we became
friends ever since I'll just read about
assah from his website assah Ali Andi is
a research fellow for y Institute member
of the Muslim debate initiative and
founder of the Andalusian
project an independent research platform
for Islamic Studies he holds degrees in
both Western and Islamic philosophy and
is currently pursuing his Masters in
library and information science he
specializes in topics related to the
philosophy of science atheism terrorism
Islamic ethics and and other issues
facing the global Muslim
Community welcome to the
show how are you
good we're
good so uh go
ahead Amar you want to say something no
I was gonna say like uh the way I heard
about you was uh from like Facebook post
of where you would just refute atheist
stuff and ex-muslims I was like pretty
awesome so I was like all right now we
get to dig into your brain a little bit
today cool uh yeah yeah I came across
you about about a year ago as well from
Facebook well was nice yeah it was nice
meeting you guys and uh it was fun going
to U and um yeah I kind of missed go I
wish I can go back but you guys kind of
went
dark now we're gonna we'll plan
something in the future
inah so biggest question that people
need to know um people are going to end
up uh the listeners okay if they're not
fathers already they're going to end up
becoming fathers and often times our
listeners are also siblings they have
siblings um they have parents they have
relatives and uh more often than than
not you hear of people within your
community leaving Islam or becoming uh
quote unquote freethinkers or atheists
or or agnostics or theists or Christians
or people basically people leaving Islam
so
my question to you is why do people why
do Muslims leave Islam particularly in
the
west well there number of factors um you
know that that could extend beyond this
conversation and I don't even think
there's enough time to address
everything in
detail uh many of it you know much of it
has to do with emotional reasons um
personal experiences with other Muslims
negative ones uh personal experiences
with the host country that a lot of
Muslims are migrating to like in the
west uh you know seeing the advances in
technology and the superiority of
certain um policies or domestic issues
or the organization of society in
comparison to their to their you know
their their home
country and or you know just being
seeped in Western culture in general
without much of a Islamic example a
superior Islamic example to compare it
to those are all um factors which you
know move people towards rejecting the
faith and uh exps themselves will say
that they're intellectual reasons
although of course I would disagree with
that that they usually cite certain
arguments or quote unquote errors in the
faith or moral issues within the faith
that lead them away um although from my
own personal experience i' I've noticed
that these are mostly rationalizations
rather than and justifications for
having already left and not necessarily
the prime
motivators so yeah I mean those those
would be like that's the general that's
the gist of
it
um I don't know if that's too concise
for you so no you yeah you mentioned
emotional reasons right like could you
like could you give examples of
emotional reasons it would something be
like uh oh my dad didn't let me go to
prom growing up uh you know I didn't
have I could have a boyfriend is
something like that A Reason yeah I mean
it's it's uh it's rather holistic in the
sense that like I said when you're
seeped into another culture you feel
restricted because that culture practic
is a certain lifestyle or certain
Lifestyles different from the one that
your parents typically want for you so
in a way it's it's moving away from from
the one that you grew up in is not only
a form of rebellion but uh other
Lifestyles look more enticing when
you're told that you can't participate
in them so in a way uh there's a sense
of freedom for moving away from your own
faith of course it is rather superficial
uh because it doesn't take into account
the the the real value the axiological
or the the ontological value of of the
particular lifestyle that you're
practicing um it's sort of a reactionary
thing and in that way it's emotional the
other way emotion sort of tie into that
is rebellion uh not just against your
parents because you know even though a
lot of exps are quite young that's part
of it but the other part is like
rebelling against your own culture your
own uh your own given identity because
when something's imposed on you um from
birth you know you feel a need to sort
of break away from it sometimes
especially if you feel a burden and that
can always and that burden can be felt
through personal experience with one's
parents friends or or you know other
family members or this community in
general so being slighted in any such
way can sort of move somebody
towards um another Direction and it's
it's quite natural to feel that way uh
but I'm not really concerned necessarily
about the motivating factors because I
feel like a lot of the motivating
factors that lead people to become exm
Muslims are largely
uncontrollable uh when I mean you can't
control the behavior of everyone around
you right you can't control a lot of
your situations in life you know you can
tell other Muslims you need to be nice
to people so they don't leave the faith
but that's not always going to stick you
know a lot of the responsibility is on
the individual so I like to focus a lot
on the psychological and the rational
factors that that they or that they
claim uh motivated them and they largely
use to rationalize and justify them
leaving because that's really where
their responsibility lies you know like
I said you can't control how your
parents act you can't control how other
people act you know if you experience
those negative things you experience
those negative
things um and that's just largely out of
your control so I like to focus on
things that you can control so that's
why I don't really focus on on those
emotional aspects I just I focus on the
arguments they use and the
rationalizations they use and see if
those are valid or
not um
yeah can we can we get into some of
those arguments that they might
use yeah common one yeah recently posted
about what I call the exome trump card
you know they do like to focus a lot on
morals and things like this and and what
they consider to be theological problems
well theology is probably the least of
their
concerns but most of all they love to
focus on the quote unquote scientific
errors in the Quran and in Islamic
scholarship in general um this is their
trump card there tends to be the primary
rationalization behind why they left the
faith although this like I said this is
always post Hawk it's something that
they only started to look into after
they left or after they wanted to leave
and now they're saying oh this is the
reason why I left uh because most the
time you can catch them they don't even
know what they're reading half the time
so for example like I said the
scientific Miracles is the biggest thing
that they go into and um and it's very
easily to easy to refute because it's
it's basically just one big straw man of
how the Quran is supposed to be read
uh traditional scholarship for the past
14400 years has generally read the Quran
in a non-scientific
way um and it's only recently become
popularized from the 19 20th century uh
after Muslims were becoming colonized in
the otom empire was falling it was is a
form of compensating for the inferiority
complex that Muslims were getting so you
know when you can see science in the
Quran now you don't have to tell
everyone that oh yeah we're we're a
religion or our culture is inferior to
the West discovered all these things
because it was already in the Quran you
know 14400 years ago we don't have to
worry uh about catching up anymore you
know because we're on par with them and
that's the reason it's really become
popular is to sort of compensate for
this inferiority that a lot of Muslims
feel and a lot of ex-muslims who left
the faith you know they kind of were
brought up in that culture where this
was a primary argument that was also
used so it's also very much the fault of
the Muslims in this respect but it's
really largely a straw man of the
Islamic schol tradition and how the
Quran should be generally read and uh
even the muslim's fault as well for
doing this because they kind of
propagate this yeah no no this is the
primary the Muslims The um's Fault in
many respects but it's not the scholarly
tradition it isn't the scholars fault
and necessarily most Scholars rejected
this this form of exoduses long before
it became popular and even afterwards
even today you have a lot of Muslim
Scholars and disis who are who are who
are on the offensive against this
methodology this approach and yet
ex-muslims refuse to address those
criticisms refuse to address what
Muslims actually believe in this respect
and they they prefer to attack low
hanging fruit you know they like to go
after zaker a lot because of his large
following but they don't go after
everyone else I me they certainly don't
go after my work even though I don't
like I don't even adopt that Approach at
all um so you know that's one of the
things they use but you also notice that
even when they tried to critique the
Quran in this way by attacking this
methodology they don't really understand
what they're reading so recently you
know I posted something about this issue
um
and an individual I think it was next
Muslim came into my post and they wanted
to show well even if the Quran doesn't
address scientific it still has
scientific errors right and and and what
the example they gave me showcases sort
of the lack of reading comprehension and
critical thinking involved in a lot of
these critiques so for example uh the
passage that they mentioned uh was um
let me see here let me just read it out
real
quick sort sort 86 I 6 through 7 and in
those aats uh if you happen to recall uh
basically says man is Created from a a
spurting fluid issuing from between the
backbone and the ribs and um you know so
their their whole entire reading of this
was quite fascinating to me because it
was so horribly wrong so the the passage
is very clear says man is Created from a
fluid that comes from between the
backbone and the ribs right and their
reading of that passage was that the
fluid comes from the backbone and from
the ribs right so not even that I bet
not even the Arabs at that time they
would have interpreted it like no no no
not even that but just the funny thing
is that the the Arabic word for for
between here is B which which is between
like for us it's it's the space between
two objects or two things
right so their reading of it was that
the fluid comes from the backbone and
from the ribs never mind the fact that
the backbone and the ribs here are
interpreted in a very different way as
well by the early Arabs because for them
they didn't have modern medical
terminology you know so for them the
backbone could find in like a whole
section of the body that was not simply
that one like the spinal it wasn't just
a spine you know it was like a very
large portion of the back area of the
human being and the ribs were not just
uh you know the ribs that we consider
there today it's also the chest bone so
and I would imagine that this claim
wouldn't be the first time that this
claim is even being made because even
the Arabs they they knew that if like
you were to castrate a camel for example
they would it wouldn't be able to make
sperm yeah I mean they they understood
these things but you know the passage
the basic the passage is very simple
it's just saying that the fluid comes
from within the body yeah exactly
basically what it's saying that's all
it's saying okay because there were some
myths back then that it actually did
come from particular areas like the
backbone of the ribs and the Quran was
just correcting that and saying no it
comes from within the body okay between
those areas and but the ex-muslims you
know they read it as though from so
showcasing their lack of reading
comprehension understanding of basic
words because when you when when you
have to completely erase the word
between there in order to make your
point it showcases that you know you
really don't know what you're talking
about You' never read anything in your
entire life so you know these very
simplistic sort of ludicrous ideas and
arguments that are being proposed in
order to rationalize their their views
and when you even bring up the fact that
this approach this whole scientific
Miracles approach just came about
recently like in the past 100 150
years it reason the ex he would
challenge you by saying that between the
backbone and the ribs well that's like
your heart that's your lungs area for
example well no because the general
thing the space between is like it
doesn't have to be the same proportion
as the objects themselves I mean for
them like I said if you if you look at
how the Arabs were were speaking back
then for them the backbone and the ribs
just the the backbone was basically your
entire
back you know the ribs was basically
your entire front portion of your body
so they weren't trying to be
anatomically correct in accordance with
modern medical terminology you know
that's not Mak sense so you know so
that's what I'm trying to say is like
not only is the objective of the Quran
not to give scientific information but a
general statement like that can be so
easily Twisted by these individuals
desperate to find a rationalization for
the re rection of their faith so this is
something that I point out
recently and this is why I also
typically don't find a lot of ex-muslims
arguments to be very convincing because
they're typically very simplistic rather
Juvenile and also very
reactive yeah I wanted to ask you a
question you mentioned uh the scientific
like you mentioned that a lot of these
guys their arguments are simplistic and
they focus on scientific critiques
critiques right or the scientific method
yeah that's so you mentioned why is it
why is it the standard of Truth is
measured by scientific method well
that's also a very recent thing as well
because even during you know prior to
the enlightenment period or even during
the Enlightenment period it was still
very
contentious um but during the elment
imperian prior science was never really
the measure of everything that didn't
really started coming about to the
positivist movement around the 17th 18th
century 18th century
primarily um well that's pre- positivism
so seem a little later than that but uh
the whole idea that science is the the
measure of all things was is really a
very recent development um post
Enlightenment and today you know even
among the lay population around the
world whether they be Muslim or
non-muslim science is is considered to
be like the authority on all things
knowledge and um like I said it's a very
recent Trend in human thinking um some
people say it's for the better I I don't
necessarily think that's the case maybe
in certain respects like when it
actually comes to subjects that are
science based and Technology based but
when it comes to like sociology religion
and and claims that fall outside of that
realm it's a very dangerous belief to
have
because um it reduces everything to sort
of physical phenomena which you know is
quite impossible really think about it
um yeah what are some of what are some
of the other challenges that people
might have that
like so have you dealt with any uh ex
like
I don't even know how to say
it so have any people ever reached out
to you to ask them like oh my son he's
not no longer a Muslim anymore several
times the lines of that so what are the
most common um contentions that they
would have and how do you deal with
number one is scientific
Miracles scientific errors quote unquote
number
two is also related to science in some
way but basically why is the Muslim
world not as advanced as the
West uh then number three usually has to
do with violence like why are there so
many terrorist in the Muslim world and
then finally I guess you could say with
the moral objections to like women's
rights and things actually it's it's
quite funny because most of the time
that I get approached even by ex-muslims
themselves uh women's issues things like
that you think that they would be like a
main thing but that's actually their
least concern um they do bring it up but
it's actually the last thing they bring
up uh and large because I think a lot of
them are are quite sexist themselves and
they really don't care uh no I'm being
frank you know because uh they come from
a lot of these exps come from certain
cultures or certain areas within that
culture that do mistreat women quite a
bit and use Islam to justify it uh
erroneously but so their their
sentiments towards women are already
quite bad so they don't seem any
problems with it they you like to use it
as like a like a a stick to beat Muslims
over the head with you know oh well how
treat women but in general they
themselves and their own families treat
women quite poorly you just go to the
ex-muslim Reddit you can find all sorts
of horrible talk speech towards
especially ex-muslim sisters there who
often not I W say sisters but you know
women who complain about the TR their
treatment by other ex-muslim
males um actually I even posted a thread
about that recently as well on my
Facebook post about all the sexual
harassment that a lot of these girls um
endure and I have been approached and
I'm not going to name names here but I
have been approached by the wives of
ex-muslims in the past uh particularly
prominent ones I and some other
individuals have been approached by uh
some some of the wives of some of these
ex-muslim figures who and they had
complained of abuse domestic abuse
emotional
blackmail theft why wait why would they
come to you well because they're still
Muslims oh but like why would they come
to you okay myself and There daa
community and they know us because we're
the only ones who are responding to a
lot of these online ex-muslims yeah so
they find us through videos or through
Network and then they go okay I need
help with this can you please help my
change my husband or something and
that's generally how the discussion
starts and then what happens is that
they go into
detail and then you realize that these
women are getting beat that they're
getting pushed out of their homes that
because they don't they because they
oppose their husband's atheism because
they yeah they didn't give in and their
husbands are like emotionally
blackmailing them refusing to give them
money if they don't become atheists I'm
not joking like it's it's really bad
there are actually some people and the
reason that I can't speak about their
names is because these women promise I
promise these particular sisters that we
wouldn't say
anything uh in you know protection for
themselves and also for their own
families and their their children but
some of them have even for have even
gone so far as to basically leave social
media alog together because some of
their husbands found out that they were
speaking to us and
threaten and we know of one particular
moderator of ex-muslim Reddit also a
famous a prominent figure who I'm not
going to name I'm just going to let you
guess who has gone out of his way to
cover up the
abuse of a lot of these sisters because
he thinks it's bad publicity for the
exposal movement
yeah like it's always uh it's always
like that's kind of ironic actually Yeah
ironic I was going to say because many
of these kufar you see amongst the
non-muslim community as well like the
abuse that they have with their women
that they're not even Muslim and we see
it right all the time with the with the
harassment and stuff well that's the
reason they pick on Islam so much and
other Muslims is because they're they're
actually projecting and compensating for
their own issues exactly like they're
the ones getting drunk and beating their
wives and whatnot no they are and
they're they're number of incidents I'm
not saying all of them but there are a
number of prominent ex-muslims who do
these things and it's actually rising
and we're just waiting for another
ex-muslim within their movement to come
out and say something but it's going to
be huge it's going to be massive you're
G to find out but you know what's going
to happen after that right very we've
already predicted what's gonna happen so
once this all get aired out all the
ex-muslims everywhere are gonna go oh
you know it's because he's still has
Islam in him that's the reason exct say
it's still Islam's fault after he left
it that's the reason
right it's like the dumbest thing
because like you see how protective
fathers are of their daughters in the
Muslim Community
right yeah I mean there are some bad
apples obviously but yeah for sure but
it's not
like but we come out and point them out
we go after them like you know the whole
recent thing with the whole uh what was
it those those fraudsters doing the
Rukia yeah
exactly uh yeah so we came out we came
out after them right Muhammad hij
we came out publicly and said these
people are frauds they're horrible blah
blah blah exwl still took advantage of
that yeah they did they
did dude they're the they're
you the guy's an atheist he literally
said yes I didn't have faith at this
point he was abusing his wives so that's
just one he was trying to force both of
his wives to become
atheists through the emotional black
Bill and you know all this other stuff
he was abusing them so this was this is
just one example that's already been AED
out yeah they're atheist yeah like yeah
I remember listening on Muhammad hijab
podcast oh sorry not Muhammed hijab my
bad muhammedan his podcast that uh the
majority the main reason why Muslims
continue to remain Muslim is because of
the Muslim Community
itself so it's typically for emotional
reasons that people um stay Muslim or or
choose to leave Islam it's not
intellectual reasons I mean the thing is
too you have to understand that part of
it yeah part of it there are emotional
see because I would never say that it's
necessarily wrong to justify your
beliefs through emotion so let me
clarify that real quick because now the
human being is more than just the
rational there also there are a lot of
things you know humans spiritual the
emotional the psychological there are a
lot of factors that are involved in
choosing one's belief and of course the
belief that you choose
has to be coherent with all those
experiences now my issue with the
ex-muslim community in particular is
that they go out of their way to
basically go oh no no we only left
because we're Superior you know we have
Superior rationality and logic we didn't
do anything based on emotion or culture
or anything like this but that's
obviously
nonsense um and they try to make it as
though you know they're Superior because
of this and that's the reason I like to
point it out a lot now if of course if
if your primary reason for staying with
a religion is emotional then I think
that is a problem I think that of course
it should be balanced out with rational
reasons and you know justifications you
can't just be like yeah because I just
happy being a yeah but but the thing is
that like most people are not smart
right well I think most have the
capacity to be I mean I think most
people are within the level of
intelligence that they can rationalize
their beliefs in a in a in a real with
you know real justification real valid
reasoning the problem is that people
refuse to do so
um you know we live in a time period
where we have more information than any
other time in history at our fingertips
we have where everything's accessible to
us and yet there are so many illiterate
people out there you know yeah by by
their own will by their own voluntary
you know
like yeah and and those people actually
they tend to be the most uh zealous in
their faith right not necessarily not
necessarily but say that people are more
certain of
themselves
uh in in uncompromising fashion
uncharitable fashion if they happen to
be willingly ignorant um so you know
going back to Exon for example you know
you have a lot of individuals who they
can't tell you basic points of Doctrine
in Islam but they're adamant that Islam
is wrong regardless of that yeah and of
course on the other side of the spectrum
you have a lot of individuals who
believe Islam wholeheartedly but they
don't even know basic AA or even just
basic fi okay
so so then why do they leave Islam to
begin with it's because of the well
typically you know it seems like the
similar similar mentality is simply
changing
sides as I pointed out in my recent post
as well you know um the reason that
ex-muslims are so fond of picking on
Lower hanging fruit or picking lower
hanging fruit is because they fell from
the same
Branch what do you mean by that they're
they're on the same level of of of
argument and intellect okay when they
left so that's the reason they go after
those things because that's the highest
thing they've ever seen they've never
studied beyond
that you know you'll never see them like
you'll never see ex-muslims attacking
the works of Al gazali or rush like they
can't they don't even understand half of
what they're being of what's being read
like they they don't they do not
understand those things they can't they
refuse yeah they can't even they don't
even understand Arabic half the time as
well when they're critiquing the Quran
on they're going off like translation oh
yeah well I mean it's okay to go off
translation here and there but my point
is because mean there's a lot of
advanced Works intermediate works even
that have been translated that you can
read and learn about Islam in depth you
know but these individuals they haven't
gone that far at all I mean like I love
it when you hear oh yeah I've studied
the Quran I read it three times in my
life it's like what like it takes it
takes me a day to read it once like what
the you know or you know or it's like
I've read three times or I've read IB
Cath and which means they've skimmed
translation of IB cath that you know and
then they're like yeah I studied Islam
and it's like all you have to do is go
to their own sources and you see that
they're wrong it's very simple um but
yeah you know it's a lot of poster
right but then you said that that there
are two reasons that people primarily
leave Islam is because number one
intellectual or number one is emotional
reasons and the second one is
intellectual reasons right no I say that
the the claim reasons as to why they
left I would say the primary reasons are
psychological and
emotional you know being seeped into the
culture that they're in and you said
that um we don't have control over that
we don't have control over the external
factors like so the things that we need
to be addressing so my Approach is that
I don't I'm not a
counselor I mean I can sit down and I
can counsel people to an extent but I'm
not a trained counselor like if you came
to me you had psychological problem or
you had an emotional trauma you know I
can't sit here and be like solve your
issue you know that's something that
that requires a professional but when it
comes to things that I think that are
within your control within your
responsibility more so at least are the
the justifications that you use for
leaving a faith so for example there's
no if your justifications don't have any
logical backing then it's not a
justification if you have no rational
means for leaving then then it's it's
not rational right and that's really
within the control of the individual
that's something that people can control
and they choose either to do so or not
to do so so that's what I typically
address um and I think that's how what
many di should be addressing and not
trying to go oh yeah well if we address
these psychological issu yeah you can
talk about them but if you're not a
professional you're not going to help
somebody who's like suffering from
bipolar
disorder you know like you know I can't
but there there are other psychological
issues that you can kind of control like
um have you seen like Prager University
by any chance yeah I watch them
occasionally for entertainment yeah so
yeah so the the reason I bring them up
is because Prager University they form
a like a sort of they conservative
intellectual intellectual Community for
conservative people yeah if you want to
call it yeah they make conservative feel
like as if they're not stupid entirely
stupid well that's
fun yeah
[Music]
so I was thinking about H like having
Muslims do something
similar like he's talking about like the
format like the idea of those little
small videos where they talk about
statistics and stuff well I I mean there
there are groups out there they're
already doing that you know to an extent
there's like um know yaken Institute and
others who are starting to pick up this
you know this sort of intellectual space
has really started to become developed
online by the Muslim Community it's
still still sort of in its early phase
but it's picking up a lot of
steam um unfortunately Muslims are
largely the problem is not necessarily
the spaces though I mean like the spaces
are being developed but the problem is
that Muslims themselves don't really you
have a group in the Muslim Community
that wants these spaces and you have
another group in the community who
doesn't care yeah it doesn't care that
that think
that it's a it's not necessary to have
these yeah yeah because they live in a
little bubble they're kind of naive or
you know wherever India or something
where they feel like their Muslims are
the majority so they don't need to do
anything but they don't see what's going
on everywhere else so they well we don't
need to address these arguments because
you know we just ignore them they'll go
away and then they then they wonder why
their their cousin or their brother or
their sister becoming an ex muscle like
why is this happening you
know take for Rukia and they take him
for Rukia they display the Quran on max
volume and hope that does
something yeah so so uh like yes so
regarding this topic of uh you know why
they're leaving and you said you focus
we focus you should focus on what we
what we can control and what they can
control so how do you go about setting
like a a stronger base for them to not
fall like go for these pitfalls like
would it be because like would it be
like hey we don't evaluate Truth by the
scientific method like what what kind of
values would you instill in someone
you know when you're teaching about or
what kind of curriculum would you or
what would what kind of curriculum would
you enforce on I think the large problem
is that you know a lot of the younger
Muslim Community especially in the west
you know they're
constantly being thrown into secular
society it's constantly bombarding them
so they don't really have a choice but
to address what they're seeing and what
they're experiencing on a daily basis
unfortunately within the Muslim
Community the minority Community or even
majority Community there is a lack of
concern for addressing these issues or
learning about these things you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of um a
lot of the strategy for a lot of Muslims
especially the first generation
immigrants is simply to
ignore or to focus their attention
elsewhere and hope that it kind of goes
away evolution is Haram not allow think
one answer you know one line responses
and just say ignore it same thing even
with sex the same thing like don't think
about it you're good that's how we solve
right and you know that that may work
back home because you're surrounded by a
lot of other Muslims who are there to
constantly remind you and yeah the
culture tells you to believe in Allah
right but when you're surrounded by 99%
of the population that doesn't have
those same values it's a little bit more
difficult um so one of the things that
I've sort of vied for in the past
several years is is that Muslims need to
start learning philosophy and a lot and
I've been met with a lot of a lot of
push back especially by the older
Generations who claim that philosophy is
Haram and it's like okay well if
philosophy is
Haram how do you expect to learn about
the philosophies that you're engaging
with you know so those philosophies are
Haram too yeah well they may but how do
you know how to address them how can you
address them if you don't understand
what they are it's like saying well
we're going to go to war with this one
nation over here but we don't know
anything about them we don't want to
know anything about them we don't know
what weapons they have and we don't care
it's like well that's not going to help
you
youil about what you're experiencing
before you yeah I think I think like
it's I think what they say well I don't
know which ones you talk to but like
from what I know I've learned that it's
when you're like when it comes to the
cats of Allah but when it comes to these
ideologies you need it right like
feminism is a type of liberalism is a
type of philosophy and they say well
you're gonna become an ex-muslim it's
like I have never met one ex-muslim that
took a philosophy
course yeah I never met one ex-muslim
who took
philosophy but thej ex Muslims I see
online they don't know they don't know
like basic logical fallacies like
they've never been in a philosophy or
they've been in a philosophy 101 course
they think because they read dekart or
Hume now all of a sudden they know
everything about
philosophy and they're they're basically
so so okay he said something very
similar like basically just don't take
your philosophy 101 or if you're going
to go Del into philosophy take the
philosophy of science and like
specialize in something and like go
yeah but what I said I said to you
earlier was that when we met is like if
you're going to take philosophy don't
think that you've learned everything
just because you've taken one
course right like everything that you're
being shown is just basic stuff like you
have to understand that philosophy this
the field of philosophy has gone on for
generations and there have been people
who have responded to the people that
you're
reading you know and unless you read
what they've said you know you shouldn't
be certain about what you're reading
because there's a for every major
philosopher out there there's somebody
who refuted them or who has tried you
know and it's a it's just a ongoing
discourse you know not one philosophy is
completely set in
stone um as the definitive answer to
everything you know and and so it's
always funny when I find like oh yeah I
I read Freud was a psychologist really
but I read uh Hume and I read dekart so
now I know every you know I know that
Islam is wrong religion is bad I'm like
are you I mean and I always look at
these I'm like are you stupid
have you ever read haiger no I've never
read haiger of course You' never read
heiger because you think Bart was
something
special you that's you know that's what
I mean it's like it's it's like the
Dunning Krueger effect if you're
familiar with that it's like um when you
when you don't know much about a subject
like your confidence in the subject is
really small but then as soon as you
learn a little bit more your confidence
skyrockets like oh I know everything as
soon as you finish the intro course you
think you know everything and then as
soon as you learn more and you become
more proficient in it your confidence in
that subject it starts to decrease and
starts shallow and then it starts to
increase back up after you've done it
for like 20 years yeah and I don't want
to just pick on exp know it's really a
sort of a cross-cultural cross
demographic issue because we live in a
world now where shallow thinking is is
sort of how should I
say um promoted and honored uh people
don't like to read Beyond a few
paragraphs and they think that if you if
you write or speak more than and what is
needed quote unquote in accordance with
most people's attention span today that
means that you're speaking nonsense so
there's these default views now that
being aerody and you know having the
sophisticated position is somehow
indicative of nonsense um which
showcases how stupid a lot of people are
now and what I mean by stupid is not
necessarily lack of intelligence but
willful ignorance right that's why
that's why I like the podcast setting a
lot that's why I like the podcast
setting is because it helps to go into
Nuance a little bit more you know but
that's why you'll see amongst SE Muslims
uh they're very popular on the internet
mostly and not within academic
communities is because on the internet
sound bites and shallow information are
considered to be
scholarship um you know what I like to
refer to and this may very rude to a lot
of people but what I like to refer to is
the intellectual peasantry you know the
have risen up
against
no of the of the intellectual world in
the Academia you know and they have
claimed now the territory of the
internet as their dominion and now
they've risen up against their
masters and you know that's what that's
what we're going to title this podcast
we're going to call it intellectual
peasantry no and it's funny because they
say and then they claim their leaders
are now their are now their their guides
you know like Richard Dawkins and Sam
Harris who are themselves intellectual
peasants and and they're not that smart
well I like to call them The Bard of the
intellectual peasantry uh the
individuals who are very good at
speaking but have lack a lot of
substance so like you know Trump is to
his base he can he convinces them with
the most vague and stupid words but he
does because he's very confident and in
the same way you know uh and maybe
that's too insulting to Sam Harris and
Etc because they do speak a little
better than Trump does but there's a
lot's a lack of substance there they
mostly wow people with their with the
way that they use their words and they
wow People based on sort of the shock
Factor and making very extreme claims
about religion and religious people do
you have any you have any examples of
that like off the top of your head well
you know Sam Harris in particular uh is
very fond of of a lot of his thought
experiments where he likes to basically
put Muslims in this camp where you know
if it goes far enough we're just going
to take over the world and kill everyone
or you know or you know if islamists
come into power which happen to be like
the majority of us for some reason um
same thing with with Ben Shapiro like he
thinks that the majority of Muslims are
radicals you saw that
yeah ad so that must mean we're all with
Isis it's like no it's
like yeah it's like it's like they lose
they'll be so nuanced about every single
topic right when it comes to every topic
but then when it comes to Islam there's
like no Nuance not even that I don't
give them that much credit I'm sorry
they're not even Nuance in other
subjects you know it's funny they do
call for nuance when they're being
critiqued yeah that's what I'm saying
when they are expressing their own
opinions it's it's it's like memery it's
it's just a meme just like well this is
stupid because you know fire with fire
we need to make we need to have like an
army of Muslim me makers well you know I
don't really want to snc to that level
that's the thing is like because I feel
like that's the sort of culture I'm
trying to I mean if that's working with
if that's
working I don't it's working in a bad
way it's working for those who it's sort
of like a a power play by idiots so like
you know so for example like you know
mobs a riot right very effective at
destroying things if you get a mob
together a bunch of you know idiots with
with pitchforks and and torches but
that's not exactly the model Society you
want you know what I mean eventually
that crumples like Hammers and power
tools and stuff and you know but that
eventually will crumble on itself
because it's not sustainable and that's
what I'm trying to say is that the sort
of knowledge that is promoted on the
internet to these days by the majority
of people and even like the explosive
movement it's not sustainable it's a
phase it'll have a large uh amount of
momentum but then eventually it's going
to fizzle because it's not long lasting
like people are still gonna be reading
Al gazali a 100 years from now nobody's
gonna be reading some idiot ex-muslim on
YouTube or watching his videos 100 years
from nobody's gonna give a crap about
them like like
AR I'm gonna bring up this too because
Army naab be brought up this really
funny like meme for example got a lot of
traction
online um going back to the whole the
simplistic you know arguments he's like
you don't need to read uh um you don't
read need to read myths to know that
they're nonsense or something and like
he said something about like Harry po I
don't know like some fiction books you
don't need to read Harry Potter to know
it's fiction and it's
nonsense right you don't need to read
these things in depth you need to learn
about them to know that they're nonsense
that's basically his argument in a
nutshell and he was arguing against this
idea that a lot of Muslims would come
back and say you need a PhD to properly
critique the subject so that's his
response and of course it's stupid
because even if something even if you
think something is fiction right say say
let's let's use this most simple example
like Harry Potter
right just because I know Harry Potter's
fiction doesn't mean
that that I don't have to read it in
order to talk about it with
authority do you see I'm like I need to
read Harry Potter to know what's in the
book like you you know I need to know if
I come out and just start saying random
crap about the book Harry Potter that's
not even in the book B and then my
justification is well I don't need to
read it to know it's stupid like that
that that is not a justification for me
being ignorant about the subject that
I'm talking
about you know imagine if somebody came
up and said about Evolution to these
people well I don't need to read
anything on Evolution to know it's
nonsense and there's but like for
example I I learned about evolution in
school but I didn't read the Origin of
Species well
yeah Authority right so for example if I
start saying that oh humans come from
monkeys that's what evolution says and
then Evolution or somebody who follows
the theory corrects me and says no
that's not what evolution says about
common ancestry and I go well I don't
need to learn about Evolution and know
it's nonsense that's my response that
looks like a cop out from my own
ignorance and of course they're gonna
you know anybody uh listening to this
podcast X something they're going to say
well you can't compare Evolution to
religion and blah blah blah and of
course that's also nonsensical that's
that's a that's irrelevant to the
objection the point is is that
regardless of whether you believe in
something or not you need to actually
study the if you want to properly
critique with any integrity and the
thing that Muslims are complaining about
is that the reason that we're saying you
need a PhD or you need some academic
qualifications is because ex-muslims in
particular islamophobes keep making
stupid arguments that have nothing to do
with our beliefs you that's the reason
why and if we don't they don't want us
to say that maybe they need to start
learning about the things that they're
talking
about right but I would say that you
have to like study the Quran
properly yeah if you have to learn how
to read if you're trying to make claims
about the about like what's inside of
the Quran but if you're talking about
like what's outside of it like whether
it's from God or not do I don't think
you necessarily need a PhD in it right
well the thing is you have to be
somewhat educated to have even a deep
discussion about certain things I mean
what are we talking about in particular
you know so for example if you want to
talk about thick like what are the laws
pertaining to
women or pertaining to to minority
rights etc etc punishments like you
can't just you know
saw on CNN so let's now I'm gonna go
talk to a scholar and try to refute him
it's like that's not how it works yeah
exactly that's that's the idea that they
have in their head that you know this is
how it's going to go that they can just
learn everything in a few minutes and
then go after somebody who studied the
subject for 20 years and just like
completely like run over them like no
that's arrogance mixed with just a
profound amount of stupidity um 100% 100
per
yeah like that too like that have a
problem with the tradition but like like
the point you bring out is a crucial one
I think where you mention how there's a
whole like and right you derive the laws
you derive the rulings so to critique
even one ruling you need to know how
they got to that conclusion before you
just critique it yeah and it's fine if
you want to reject something based on a
simplistic understanding like say if you
like I reject Christianity based on
certain theological issues yeah but
those issues is what I will argue only
those issues I won't go after everything
else in Christianity Not Having learned
about it and I definitely won't go
marching up to the Vatican and try to
argue with the Pope you know you know oh
I know more than you Mr Pope about
everything that I'm talking about like
no I'm not I'm not that I'm not
stupid you know um now there is a point
you know that I will come from where I'm
saying like you know I don't believe the
Trinity is correct because I think it's
it's theologically invalid I think that
there are some logical inconsistencies
there and I do feel that it's incoherent
and and on that level I can disagree
with him but if if I'm going to go in
and be like yeah you know Christianity's
views on women when I haven't study the
subject right in
depth but this is how a lot of these
people act they go let me go look up
something that confirms my bias go
article for five minutes and then they
try to go after people who have phds in
the subject they're
[Music]
idiots yeah I I agree with that like and
you you you even see it with yourself
right were people chicking out of
debates with you most of the time it's
happened a few times um you know and
it's actually kind of made me mad
because um partly it
confirms a lot about these people but I
wish I had a larger base so that it
could be sort of marketed that these
people are cowards unfortunately I don't
so it's easy for them to run away and
kind of have this sort of you know not
really noticed but you know when I when
I've gone after Robert Spencer and David
wood and they were Ned on debates with
me and brother fad you're very much
aware of what happened to Robert Spencer
I'm hoping to release that video soon by
the way it's been a long time but um you
know it the moment that they learn that
I know more than they do and I'm very
proud to say that I don't care because
it's true um all it arrogant all they
want but I've educated myself I humbled
myself for several years at University I
have a right to say that and if they
don't like it they can kiss my
ass you know so sorry excuse my friend
you know but my point is is that you
know these IND idual are so
arrogant that they're willing to talk
down to me and other people who have
studied more than they have and when
challenged in an academic a fair
academic platform they make so many
excuses just to back out of
it um you
know the fact that Robert Spencer for
example and this is one of the biggest
insults I've ever had in my life and it
was expected but it was still
insulting you remember we we offered him
a fair platform at OSU at Ohio State
University one of the largest
universities on in the
country okay security free security
travel everything everything he
complains about not getting because he
always complains on Twitter that nobody
wants to invite him to universities
they're trying to censor him we invite
him give him a red carpet what happens
he claims that we're a security
risk he claims that the MSA the students
at OSU Muslim Students are a security
risk for
him then he the main thing is that he
asked for like $20,000 $20,000 for his
own personal security which you don't
even need for personal security to
protect himself from all these evil
possible terrorists in the
MSA yeah but the the guy he's had
a uh assassination attempt on him once
he claims in Iceland which is not even
true it was about some stupid thing with
like some guy put ecstasy in his drink
and then trying to get him like trying
to get him to party yeah and then yeah
he was uh I think it was in where was it
Texas somewhere he had like some drama
mamed day thing and these two Lone Wolf
idiots went and tried to kill him and
then the FBI basically took him down you
know so nothing actually happened they
shot at the building or whatever but
nobody got hurt uh no that's that's a
pretty big thing though it's a big thing
but think about it was that a university
was there security everywhere was it
like you know I mean look why the heck
would we invite and spend money on a guy
to come in just so we could kill him
like I'm sorry I'm not going to waste my
time you know I'm not there I want him
to be alive I want to embarrass him in
front of people I don't want to kill him
I'm not gonna waste my precious life
going to jail for some idiot like him I
mean no okay stop don't flatter yourself
Robert okay I have more important things
to do with my time than worry about your
life all right seriously and this is the
thing that he doesn't get he wants to
make this is an excuse like I said and
let's look at it from a princip like the
matter of principle okay if you are
anything like a man
okay you wouldn't require $20,000 for
your
convictions if you had any semblance of
testicles okay you wouldn't sit here and
claim that you need security so you can
speak about your beliefs in an
intellectual manner on an intellectual
platform at a
university if you're not willing to die
for your free speech and expression or
even you know somebody yelling at you or
something then I'm sorry you don't have
convictions you don't deserve to have
conviction and you may as well just go
toow somewhere else and never speak
again because you know for me like
you're you're not worth you're not worth
your words and maybe that's a hard thing
to ask for a lot of people like you know
they don't want to risk their lives and
stuff but like I said for somebody to
come out and say he's Brave and that
he's trying to help Western Civilization
he's fighting for free speech and
everything and free
expression yeah oh crap like no he's not
he's fighting for himself he's posturing
and and you know he's just a little
weasel no it's true I mean he can come
out and he can say the Muslims are being
mean to me it's like no you deserve it
you don't deserve respect when you don't
have any dignity for yourself or anybody
else like and that's that's and I'm
sorry to go on a rant about him but you
know it does it infuriates me that
people think these sort of people are
brave and have anything intellectual to
offer when they have zero integrity and
they can't even they don't even have
enough courage to stand up on a fair
platform at a
university uh to debate their
ideas he has to go Scurry away in some
church with private security because you
know he thinks he's in such
danger pathetic and I'm sorry if if that
was too much but you know for me it's
just it's really I agree with you
100% 100% I'm being blunt because and
I'm sorry if you know if I'm using
certain words but you know I I want to
be very Frank here that you know these
people
anyone who looks up to these individuals
has no Integrity has no principle they
don't they're not an ethical person um
as far as I'm concerned I have never
asked for a fee speaking out against
Isis when I was
overseas okay when when they called me
to go give speeches at at universities
or places where there were actually Isis
members in the crowd and who wanted to
kill me I didn't go hey I need $20,000
for you guys to give me security before
I go there wait wait is that confirmed
that there were Isis members in the
crowd where you were speaking at in
Malaysia there were some members who
were watching me yes and I got
threatened personally by a few of them
so how wait how did they threaten you to
my face wait what they they were like yo
we're going to kill you shut up or we're
first off like it was kind of like it
was very subtle so first off they were
basically like I don't think you should
speak brother because you know it's very
sensitive subject and I try to explain
to them that no it needs to be said and
then uh you know that com conversation
eventually blew up to the extent where
it was like if you talk you know you're
going to find yourself
dead and so said that huh yeah I mean it
was more graphic than than that um like
one guy basically said you know I will
call I will saw your head
off so and uh I kind of like I kind of
like stood up to him and and he just
shouted and kind of backed off with his
friends but you can tell who is who wait
how many how many people were there can
you can you describe this incident a
little bit it was a group of like four
people it's not I mean where are they
from syrians oh snap oh God so you know
what they what are they doing in
Malaysia
studying what studying at the
University oh damn so no I mean they got
rooted out eventually uh you know when
the Crackdown happened in Malaysia those
those individuals were arrested and
deported uh but
um yeah there were there were members
like what I'm trying to say is that look
I don't think much yes our lives are
important our family's lives are
important but if you're coming out here
and you're trying to act like you're a
brave man and you're trying to fight for
free SP you know free expression and
Free Speech in the face of danger in the
face of violence and you're trying to
promote you know all of these things and
you're trying to be like this Idol for
people and then you come out and you're
like I can't go over there because
they're going to kill me it's like you
know you you look like a complete
clown
you see what I'm trying to say
like 100% yeah like you have you have to
put your you have to put your skin in
the game if you're really like yeah it's
like what imagine if Martin Luther King
was like yeah I'm fighting for civil
rights and I'm willing to die but get
you know I need bodyguards around me 247
just in case and I can't speak in public
because I'm
worried like no that would have never
worked I was listening to this podcast
Yesterday by quintus cius about the
difference between recklessness and
courage H so I think he thought that
like I I think that Robert Spencer would
think that going to this uh debate would
be
Reckless reckless in what than being
courage reck no evidence putting his
life he's putting his life on the line
for no reason whatsoever there's no
evidence that he was even putting his
life on the line to begin with he's just
appealing to the the uh Prejudice of
common of his community
you know it's very easy this is this is
a very easy way of getting out of debate
for a lot of exp islamophobes oh yeah
I'm willing to debate with you but you
might be a
terrorist yeah it helps them to continue
like continue promoting this narrative
that we're all dangerous while at the
same time you know on the other side of
their mouth they're denying the fact
that they hate all Muslims or they think
all Muslims are dangerous people so you
might be a terrorist so I can't risk my
life but yes I am willing to speak but I
can't speak to you you you see so they
can they don't ever have to debate
anyone right because they can always
appealing to that prejudice of the
society oh yeah he's right yeah those
Muslims might be
dangerous so Abdullah alusi my cousin
had a very similar situation
happened he was about to debate an
atheist they had this plan for weeks
okay he gets to the venue guy calls out
says I'm worried about
security of course debate
okay all his followers are like yeah we
understand you know he might you might
have been killed by those evil Muslims
in the audience who wanted to blow you
up because you're you're preaching out
against their
ideas see it helps to further that
stereotype that negative stereotype
while at the same time giving off this
veneer that you're still being
intellectually honest and you're willing
to have discussion with
people right saves your skin while at
the same time it helps you to continue
demonizing the people that you're
attacking yeah
excuses and no it's like it's like even
these so-called a lot of the non-muslim
like so-called freeth thinkers and like
classical liberals they'll never invite
they'll never invite a traditional
Muslim on their show right like you see
Dave ruin or Joe Rogan right he's always
like oh I'm openminded this and that who
does he invite about Islam like
imagine didn't he bring F zabi okay
that's like one most that's one example
of like a practic but that that's not
what they talked about that was not the
main topic but Dave okay so Dave Ruben I
messaged him I gave him Anil said
because he's had uh people on his show
ex IMI does not count as uh he had IMI
on there who
does m Gaff on there yeah he had all
these he's had all these exps on there
and I came on there and I said hey I'm
studying this and this and I'd love to
have a discussion with you why don't you
never got back to me he's never had one
and he will never will you'll never see
these people go on there yeah exactly
all about that follow isn't it well no
it's not even about follower count
because I recognized by these guys right
no there's many there's many examples of
like bigger Muslims let's use let's use
an example let's use Hamza YF right why
don't they talk to
him
y yeah like exactly it's not about
follower count it's they only they're
Liars right they're not open to
discussion they're only like they only
talk to people that if you think about
it even though there's a lack of
Integrity there it's a good strategy
because you see what they're doing is
actually they're saturating their own
Market Market with a particular
Viewpoint if they bring in a counter one
and they actually show balance it'll
undermine what they're trying to do see
their whole purpose whether you whether
they want to admit it or not is to show
that there isn't an intellectual
response from our side yes exactly is
that are barbarians that we're stupid
underdeveloped people who can't give any
sort of response that the only thing
that we will do is try to kill you if
you disagree with us but if we came on a
show say you bring an intellectual
Muslim who studied right onto their show
and debating with them then it destroys
that narrative because it shows that yes
we do want to have discussion yes we can
have discussion yes we are intelligent
and that's not what their followers want
to see and that's not the The Narrative
they want to promote so even just going
like say they invited me and I'm not
saying on the best I'm saying like y
cling others are better but let's say
they invited me or or somebody else and
I go on there um without me even having
to say anything I've already won the
discussion because I've destroyed the
narrative that they're trying to promote
yeah that they don't want that for them
right yeah they don't want a guy that
went to Malaysia studi the religion
academic they don't they don't want a
guy in general there because as soon as
you bring on a guy you like as as said
you ruin the narrative and the narrative
is that all these Muslims they don't
want to talk but as soon as you bring
one on that just proves that oh they do
want to talk yeah and they don't they
can't have that because all the
ex-muslims they bring on there are like
yeah we're so in danger you know because
we can't have these discussions like
we're having right now this is
civilization we're having really good
int ual discourse but you can never have
this with a Muslim person that's what
they always say do you do you hear that
every time they have liar so if they if
they brought somebody on it would
completely undermine everything 100%
like there're like this just shows you
their intentions are not trying to find
the truth or explore different
viewpoints or build Bridges they don't
want to do that of course not right this
is why we have to protect from the
outside you know by by trying to
critique them from the outside and they
don't try to give us any like any um uh
publicity or if they do give us
publicity like what they'll do is
they'll try to quot mine us and try to
make us look out to be terrorist or
radicals or something right like look
what they did to
Daniel yeah wait what
did so when they had him on like when
Army naabi oh yeah the debate with that
wasn't a debate oh my God
IM right the whole point of that or even
when the secular jihadists like when
they had me on or when they had Daniel
on they were trying to throw us into a
corner and one of the reasons they'll
never invite me back to their show is
because I refused to be put in that
corner um you know I don't know if you
noticed this discussion but uh if you
saw that discussion what they were
trying to do is like I came prepared so
the whole topic was about is Terrorism
you know is Islamic terrorism actually
Islamic that was a whole
discussion and I brought on like studies
I had like papers and books next to me I
had like a whole list of references
ready to go you know with all these
psych excited and
like and in the middle of the
discussion I brought it up I said look I
have all these studies so if you want to
talk about them all the evidence that
goes against your theory and do you know
what happened I kid you not they're like
no no no let's let's let's go on
something
else I'm not joking that's exactly what
was said to
me wow I need to go watch this no if you
go watch that I mean I might upload on
my channel eventually I'm still doing
some editing because the audio is pretty
bad but they have it on their own
channel that literally happened that
literally happened the very thing they
called me to come on
discussing they changed the subject in
the middle of the discussion when I
decided to say oh yeah I want to bring
in this academic evidence I have all
this stuff waiting here let's let's talk
about it like no no no let's just have a
talk and they switched it to like
something like about Hellfire or
something I was like what does this have
to with you know
the yeah what a [__] move you asked me
to you asked me to rant this is me
ranting I don't even know what talking
about
anymore you want to go to the we have
actually two more questions okay can I
ask those so you studied uh Western
philosophy right as well as Islamic
Studies yeah right so I mean you you
didn't just study Western philosophy any
you hated it all the time you you
probably enjoyed some parts of it I enjo
found some parts of bit useful right
yeah I enjoyed the uh I enjoyed the
exercise of my brain yeah yes
so what ideas do you think are like the
most useful or which ideas did you enjoy
the most pragmatism pragmatism yeah I
mean PR I'm I'm yes I am I mean
obviously you guys know this so but
what's the pragma what is it to explain
this to Amar because Amar doesn't get
which is the American School of
philosophy uh the primary American
School of philosophy is called
pragmatism it was developed primarily in
the Americas now actually let me correct
that because even um William James would
disagree with that with that notion um
although the formal School known as
pragmatism was developed in the Americas
primarily North
America um pragmatism as a philosophy
itself has existed for quite some time
and William James even said that himself
that it's just a name for something old
in old way thinking and pragmatism is
basically very simply put it's believing
in things or believing in in ideas and
things because they
work and what is that by workability
workability for a pragmatist is
basically how does it cohere with your
other experiences and your understanding
of the world and how well does it uh
make sense of everything else that's
basically it it's not based on any sort
of direct validity like like say
concordance like I have to see something
in order to verify that existence of
that thing uh it has a lot to do more
with whether like your brain is a puzzle
basically or your way of looking at the
world is like a puzzle okay you have
bits and pieces of imagery right so what
a pragmatist will do is is say okay well
how's the best way what's the best way
of getting a full picture
here the data that I
have oh wait continue continue so that's
what a pragas will do they'll develop
theories on the basis of how well they
can organize and make things coherent in
their brain and whether that theory is
workable towards doing what does what
does workable mean like workable means
being able to make things coherent uh it
also can pertain to
predictions um whether things will come
true as a
result uh whether a prediction comes
through as a result of the theory you've
chosen um it can also mean whether or
not it works in the sense that your life
is
benefited okay you a person feel
complete or feel whole or feel like
everything makes sense around you like
can explain things can the theories that
you've chosen the beliefs that you've
chosen explain your experiences in a
good way without any contradictions
without any um opposition or significant
opposition
um if your theory doesn't work it means
that another what it means is like if a
theory is weak say another Theory comes
along that explains things better that
means that that works
better than the one that you've adopt
that's what pragmatism is it's not about
whether you can empirically verify or
whether you can necessarily logically
everything has to be logically uh
verified or something right it's it's
all about it's actually can incorporate
both empirism and rationalism within it
can can you give examp examples of uh
yeah yeah I just want to ask before like
the examples like I guess this would be
an example like say you're a Christian
and you're a pragmatist and say you're a
Muslim and a pragmatist how how does how
like how does that person operate on
their beliefs and how would how would
the Muslim convince the Christian to
become Muslim in light of pragmatism the
pragmatists this is how pragmatists
resolve the issue of of differing
beliefs say Christian meets the Muslim
and they're both pragmatist okay and
they both have their own paradigms right
now the Muslim will bring up something
about his beliefs and the Christian will
bring up something beliefs now there's
the
contention they both in one God so
that's fine but then they get to the
whole Trinity thing and crap okay so
like wait a minute something's wrong
here so now they've both experienced an
anomaly um the Christian has experienced
an anomaly in that the Muslim believes
that God is not three people just one
and then the Muslim has experienced an
anomaly because the Christian saying
well there are three persons in one and
Jesus God etc etc now the first thing
they're going to do is they're going to
look through their beliefs their
paradigms individual paradigms and
determine whether or not those
particular anomalies can fit within the
Paradigm now they both probably come to
the conclusion that no that's not the
case so if something is wrong either I'm
wrong the Muslim either one person's
wrong or the other the person they're
speaking to is
wrong right so now how do we determine
which is
right that's when we start looking at
the coherence of both paradigms uh and
whether or
not um the experiences of each
individual both in religious experience
both in scriptural experience Etc
conforms uh better to their theories so
how do that's very vague so let me give
you an example so let's look at internal
coherency the Muslim challenges the
Christian and says okay so you say God
is one but the three
persons right how does that work and the
Christian explains it but for the Muslim
his his view is actually more simple
it's like well we don't have three
people we have one person or one there's
one being right so that's a much more
simple explanation why is your more
complex explanation preferable to
mine that would be the first question
that should be asked by the Muslim why
is that
preferable now whether the Christian can
rationalize it or not will determine how
much they've thought about their
beliefs um but that's actually a very
important question why is it preferable
and that's something something that many
people don't ask when they have
disagreements why is your theory
preferable to my theory now the
pragmatist would say one mine's more
simple two yours is more
confusing that's a problem for a
pragmatist but how is this okay uh not
TR but how is this different than
something logical because the three in
one thing just logically it doesn't make
sense kind of you can kind of if you use
like Aristotelian metaphysics or
actually neoplatonism you can actually
rationalized the three you got to Define
these things as you go along so
substance and Essence so like I'm sorry
so the accidents and the essence so so
they consider the persons to be
accidents or or or
attributes not attributes but like
basically the essence is one
thing so there's one God in essence but
he's three persons Med Essence yeah
that's yeah they'll have some sort of
rationalization we'll rationalize it
that way so for a priv is first thing
would be like okay which of these is
more simple and which one is too
convoluted that's one criteria now it
doesn't always pass right so sometimes
things can be very complex so what's the
next step okay well as a pragmatist it
should be internally consistent with my
other beliefs so one thing Christianity
has a problem with is imut so first off
Christians believe that God is immutable
perfect and Perfection includes the idea
that one cannot lose something one
cannot become
decreased you know
that thing is is as it is and always
will be cannot
change is example like can't give up
anything you can't do anything right the
other problem though Christianity has is
also something else is Central to his
Doctrine which is the concept that God
sacrificed
something now sacrifice implies a
loss right you have to give something up
of
yourself right but God can't lose
anything
because then if he was able to lose
anything he would not be God yeah so
according to their own definition so
there's an internal inconsistency there
now Christians can respond and say well
you know he didn't really give up
something because he you know he didn't
really sacrifice that's just a word he
used for us it's like well if he didn't
really sacrifice something then what was
the significance of the
sacrifice right see sort of words a prag
would
ask it gets to the sacrifice it's not is
it logically necessary or can it be
empirically verified no I'm asking
what's the
consequence of your
ideas is it consistent with your other
beliefs what's the
significance compared to my belief does
that
really is that
preferable that's what a pragmatism has
and that's actually for a pragmatis
that's the most important qualities of a
belief are its consequences are its
benefits are whether or not it's
coherent with your other viewpoint
is whether or not it's a better
explanation is whether or not it's more
simple or too complex okay so the more
simple part the simp the simple part is
that is that an inherent trait of all
pragmatists regardless of theology um
that would be one S I guess you could
call one Axiom yeah is whether or not
it's not necessarily that the more
simple theology is the better one is is
whether or not the more simple ex is
whether the more simple explanation can
explain the thing
still see because you can have two the
iCal positions and one's more complex
than the other but if they don't explain
the same things then it's it's pointless
to compare their
complexity or their Simplicity to each
other but if we have the concept of like
one God and one theology has a better or
more simple understanding of that that
explains it in just like in just the
same way but without all of the
convoluted nonsense that's
unnecessary then you know it's more
preferable explanation it shows that the
theory is more
um
efficient so for example aam's razor is
a pragmatist
principle which is which is basically
the most more simpler explanation is the
more one or it's the correct one or the
one we go with we don't say it's more
it's more useful right okay so like in
this case as a pragmatist as a Muslim I
say well our theology is the most simple
one yeah explains everything that you
said but without all the added crap
yeah and our theology is consistent with
our other beliefs whereas yours causes a
lot of
problems right like the dying dying for
the sins but that sacrifice but also
dying like okay so what happened so if
Jesus died he's a third person of the
Trinity then you're telling me God
changed because then only be it dropped
down to two people in three
days oh yeah no but wait a minute no no
no he didn't really die
just his body died okay well then how
did he
die his human body died okay well for
god that's nothing like what what did he
what did he give
up like he gave up a shell of himself
that's not a big deal like do you think
God would be affected by
that what about like in um how has
pragmatism been used in
science on
oh you you want to continue with this no
I wanted him
to of the pragmatist perspective like
you know the whole thing like you in in
the Contemporary world we have issues
with you know uh gender roles very
contentious issue you know women and men
should be equal in everything that they
do and say of course Human Society has
not functioned like that ever yeah so
you'd ask why and there are biological
differences between men and women that
are very obvious I mean that's not say
that women and men should abuse each
other obviously not but there are
certain roles that men and women are
suited for and Islamic ethos accounts
for that and and promotes that very
natural
position uh whereas you know other
beliefs don't so I mean which one really
is more in Conformity with The Human
Experience and and and and more natural
to The Human Experience than than others
you know these are things that that the
pragmatist would ask it's not
necessarily oh is it true because truth
to a pragmatist is really is not some
absolute thing I know it's it's whatever
I want it's like have you ever seen like
The Avengers like the newest one yeah
I've seen them all there's a there's
this one meme in it that says like truth
is whatever I want it to be than says
that that's not really is that what
private like because some some people
would have that kind of misconception
about privatism is that like oh if it's
more useful or if it's something that I
that's even NE that's a neist position
because neist would say there's no
objective meaning there's no absolute
meaning or purpose to the universe we
make our own meaning and purpose that's
not it's not kind of what a pragmatist
would no that's not a pragmatist would
say basically whatever works the best is
closest to the truth that you can get
the prst would also say that you don't
know 100% of everything so you can't
have absolute knowledge of subject
matter you know so whatever's what is
true to a pragmatist is what is the best
what is the most the best working model
but at the same time they wouldn't say a
pragst would not say that is absolutely
the case like there's always room for
error you know what I'm trying to say
like in terms of methodology not in
terms of belief because you know when
you actually believe
something um you can't doubt you can't
well yeah you can't well you don't it's
it's kind of actually unnatural to do
so I'll give you can I give a really
good example of like why you should be a
pragmatist yeah so say you know you
can't prove that you're not in the
Matrix right yeah me an example I gave
you was was this was this the example
you gave
me tell it okay then you can yeah you
can tell it then so you can't prove that
you're in The Matrix yeah it's true you
can't prove that you're in some computer
simulation if somebody come up to you
and said yeah bro we're in The Matrix
right well but you can't prove that
you're not in it e to first
off what is the default here um the way
that we come to doubt things is based on
whether or not we've experienced an
anomaly in our B in our daily and basic
experiences so if I walk outside and I
use this example a lot if I walk outside
right now and I look outside I see my
Tre I have a bunch of trees outside so
if I look at my apple tree my front yard
okay I don't go out every morning and go
is that really an apple tree you know
I've just already I assume that's an
apple tree because that's what I've seen
and I'm just going to continue assuming
it's an apple tree until something
changes in my experience that makes me
doubt
that now according to theep iepc or
somebody who constantly requires
empirical or rational validity for
everything they're going to go well to
be consistent they have to every time
they experience an object they have to
actually utilize their methodology in
order to verify that that thing actually
is the
case
okay now a pragmatist says that's
nonsense I'm not going to do that
because I need to
live like I can't walk out every day and
doubt whether or not I'm in reality
because I wouldn't be able to
function you know I have to take a lot
of things for granted in order for me to
even have knowledge of the
world right I have to believe that I'm
in reality that I'm that I'm experien
that what I'm experienced is actually
there in order for me to even move
forward if I'm constantly doubting
everything and I have to require
justification for everything that I see
immediately you know in my immediate
preview then I'll never get anywhere I
won't I won't be able to I won't be able
to take the the first
step so proba says the hell with all of
that you know basically take things for
granted as long as they work and until
they don't work then you have an issue
to
resolve okay what wasm in response of no
as long as they work right like what is
it like as long as they work with your
reality and perception of life like for
example if you're a Christian right and
you've never experienced another
religion in your life there's no reason
for you to go oh
is my
Christianity you know is there something
wrong with it you don't know there's an
alternative you never experienced an
alternative right right until you
experience that alternative and you
until you experience an anomaly in your
faith then you start thinking about
which one works the most in in in
understanding my
world but in the meantime the most
coherent explanation that you have is
the one that you should adopt because
that's the only one you can adopt you
see what I'm saying the pragmatis breaks
everything down in simple ways like that
like basically you only you adopt what
you can and what you
should uh based on the resources the
intellectual resources or the the the
the amount of data that you have at your
disposal so whatever makes sense to my
little brain um I should consider that
to be true for all intents and purposes
think about it though is there any other
way to go about it
no I if you really think about it you
know you really don't have a choice in
that matter whatever you've experienced
or what your mind is already used to uh
understanding about things is really all
you have that's the only tool set you
can't you can't import tools that you've
never seen or don't have any knowledge
of right and even in the event that you
have other tools around you just like we
live in the information age so we can
look online and see a lot of things go
to the library
Etc you have to look at those tools and
compare them you see which which of
these um is more reliable for
me and there's a comparison and contrast
that occurs between those those those
those things and those
events but this idea that you everything
you come across every experience you
have to doubt or you have to validate
validate based on some other methodology
so a pragmatist that's just that's like
that makes you a disfunctional human
being and that's not actually how people
act or behave at all no it's not there's
so many things you can't empirically
prove that you accept it's not even
rationally it's like look dude if I'm
walking outside and things are
working you know as long as I'm like
hallucinated you know I'm not seeing
like pink elephants flying across the
sky things are okay you know what I'm
saying like you know what I'm saying
like the structures that we live in even
the cultural structures the religious
structures government structures that we
live in if we don't have any knowledge
of anything else that works better than
that you really you really don't have
any
justification for doubting it or even
going against it and even in the event
that something does come and challenges
that if that thing is not good enough at
explaining that information or that data
or that or those experiences then you
have no reason to to to leave your other
Faith what ex Muslims a lot of people do
is that they see an alternative and they
just jump over
immediately without even questioning
whether or not the other one is
sustainable or adequately actually
addresses their
concerns you know one of the things that
you see a lot of when when the a lot of
Muslims fall to
atheism they have a terrible time
explaining morality they love to
complain about so many things if you
explain principles they're like well
it's all subjective it's like well what
the hell are youing about like why you
yeah they claim there's no objective
standard for Morality but then they
moralize anyways yeah they act like
there
is yeah the other thing that prag does
and I didn't mention is that
pragmatists are very much about
actions your beliefs and your actions
correspond should correspond with each
other should I mean it doesn't that
you're a non-believer if you don't act a
certain way but if you act consistently
opposed to what you actually say then
there's a then you don't actually
believe that
thing so whenever I come across people
who constantly moralize and constantly
bash Islamic ethics yet at the same time
claim that there's no real meaning
purpose or behind anything that they're
talking
about then what comes to my mind is that
you don't actually believe
that that makes no sense for why why
does the pragmatist value that value
what value value uh consistency between
thoughts and
actions why why is this significant
because for something to work it has to
manifest itself in some way so
workability in terms of coherence means
just consistency that means that it
doesn't contradict your other beliefs
and that it easily organizes data and
information workability also applies a
physical
manifestations you know if you're if you
a moral a moral claim requires a moral
action by necessity
so for example one of the reasons that I
was bashing Robert Spencer earlier is
because he doesn't act in accordance
with his principles he's not congruent
with his principles no he's he's very
much a coward and he doesn't actually
believe in the things he claims he's
postering I I still don't see why why
it's important to a pragmatist for yeah
like as a Muslim if you commit a sin
aren't you contradicting like your
principles okay so let me put it this
way if you claim to me here's what a
pragmatist says and I think this is very
easy to understand if you say that
prayer is require is required for you to
be a Muslim yes and you refuse to
pray ah
okay that why is that important to a
pragst it shows an inconsistency between
one's actions and and
beliefs right refusing to pray is
different from for like forgetting yeah
or like yeah so then we we a PR will say
you don't actually believe that well
they you have a justification because
then it shows that your theory is not
working it's not making you do anything
that you claim that you need to do so
why should a Muslim be a pragmatist or
why should they not
be why should a person be a pragmatist
let's put it that way in general yeah in
general like because I what's the
alternative right because a pragmatism
and and one of the excuse me I'm gonna
get up real quick here for
pragmatist um one of the beauties of
pragmatism is that is what we call a a
metame methodology or meta theory in
many respects because
it actually is it can incorporate so
many different methods under one
umbrella a pragmatist can also be an
empiricist and ration basically a prag
can be an empiricist and IR rationals at
the same
time they can be everything at the same
time because what they're looking for is
not
necessarily um whether you can see it or
whether it makes perception what they're
looking for is what works towards
achieving a particular goal of coherency
organization so at any given time that's
why some people are confused about what
I believe in sometimes because sometimes
I'll adopt empirical methodologies for
say scientific claims but other claims
I'll I'll adopt only purely logical
rational methods they go how can you do
that and I go because I'm a pragmatist I
I choose whatever the heck I want or
whatever it's yeah whatever works
whatever is the most coherent whatever
helps to and and they say well doesn't
that contradict no it doesn't actually
because I just demarcate between which
method is necessary for when and for
what yeah I'll give you an example you
know like black what's it called Dark
Matter yeah you want you want to
continue I was going to say like it's
the same with having a toolkit I'm not
gonna use a hammer for
everything right I gonna say like you
know Dark Matter yeah so there's no
empirical verification for dark matter
like no like no one's seen it no one's
experienced it no one's measured it but
the only reason why we think it is it
exists out there is because um because
the physics tells us so like like our
our mind is predicting that our our mind
our math our physics is predicting that
dark matter is eventually going to exist
or like it's going to like we're going
to ever we're going to experience it at
one
point okay so our mind with the from the
practice perspective our mind predicts
it or experiences it through the
knowledge of
physics is that so it doesn't experience
it but
like saying that dark matter does exist
is the most pragmatic explanation for
what we
have does that make sense so do you mind
if I just explain something that U yeah
let's let's have exp he's the expert so
sorry okay so William James is is in
lecture three of his
book he's trying to explain pragmatism
and its worth in terms of like Theology
and this is just one
um quote among many so it's just a few
paragraphs it won't be too long though
so he's talking about Free Will at first
and it's really interesting he says uh
Free Will thus has no meaning unless it
be a doctrine of relief as such it takes
its place with other religious doctrines
between them they build up the old waste
and repair the former desolations our
spirit shut within this Courtyard of
sense experience is always saying to the
intellect upon the tower watch men tell
us of the night if it is ought of
Promise bear and the intellect gives it
then these terms of Promise other than
this practical significance the words
God free will Design Etc have none have
zero significance outside of their
practicality or The Human
Experience he says yet dark though they
be in themselves meaning though their
definitions have no meaning by
themselves or intellectual uh
intellectual taken when we bear them
into life's Thicket with us the darkness
there grows light upon us if you stop
and dealing with such words with their
definition alone thinking that to be an
intellectual finality where are you he
goes on to say it means less than
nothing in its pompous robe of
adjectives pragmatism alone can read a
positive meaning into these words and
for that she turns her back upon the
intellectualist point of view altogether
God's in the in his uh in his Heaven
alls right with the world that's the
real heart of your theology and for that
you need no rationalist
definitions uh he goes on to say why
shouldn't all of us rationalist as well
as pragmatist confess this pragmatism so
far from keeping her eyes bent on the
immediate practical foreground as she is
accused of doing dwells just as much
upon the world's remotest
perspectives and then finally he says um
the real vital question for us all is
this what is this world going to be what
is life eventually to make of itself the
center of gravity of philosophy must
therefore alter its place the Earth of
things long thrown into Shadow by the
glories of the upper ether must resume
it's right Etc he goes into very poetic
you Pros here but essentially what he's
trying to say is like you talk about all
these abstractions right you talk about
what God is what free will is all these
things right but unless it has any
relevance to my actual lived experience
it doesn't
matter it means nothing right yep so
when we talk about God for example in
Islam do we just talk about God in his
attributes what I mean is the abstract
sense or do we talk about his attributes
and how they're relevant to us how
they're relevant to us right exactly
right right because can't talk about
them any other
way yeah that makes sense
yeah saying you can't be a pure
empiricist or a pure rationalist okay I
I kind of get it most people unknowingly
already behave as pragmatists yes that's
he considers it the natural way of
thinking yeah always whats for us in our
minds and in our lives we don't think
about what's right or what's true
in the abstract objective sense that
it's removed from
ourselves we never do is this basically
the philosophy of like
the our uncles like our
community T was a very well-known
pragmatist how so uh one of the reasons
that he backed the idea that God exists
is because uh human beings are naturally
inclined to it and that to do otherwise
be to make them confused
yeah that was basically his whole
rationale behind the the tells
you he said he made a consequentialist
argument he said if to deny the fitro is
to put man in
confusion and to put man in confusion is
to lose sight of himself in the world
yeah that was his that was his
justification like that was literally
the reason why he believed in
God okay yeah
W it's like if because if you don't then
what else you gonna see
how else are you going to behave as a
person like there is no other way for
people to
be yeah same thing with morality he said
why do I believe in in in Transcendent
morality through my fitra because to do
otherwise would be to throw the world
into chaos throw man into chaos to
destroy what it means to be
human that that was basically his
reasoning right
you are they like yo man are Daisy
ancestors abar you and I and then you my
an ain't Daisy get out of
here W afan is trying to essentially is
that yes this is the natural way of
thinking and all we're trying to say is
that you do not choose on the basis of
abstractions or on the basis of even
whether or not something um looks
convincing what you choose is based on
how does it affect you in the way the
world and
that is a pragmatic
concern wow that is not Truth for the
sake of it there's no such thing as a
pragmatist doesn't say you you believe
something for the sake of it that makes
no sense to a pragmatist that's
meaningless you don't love Truth for the
sake of it you don't love knowledge for
the sake of
it now you love it because it affects
you does that make it makes sense yeah
no I can see no so even even if someone
is saying I believe in this because for
the sake of
it in reality it's actually because it
affects them in a certain way well it's
because it makes them well if you want
to go deep into it's because that makes
them it makes their experiences feel
coherent and organized it makes them it
helps them to make sense of the world it
helps them to function in the world so
two plus two is four not because
necessarily is true but because it's
useful exactly well mathematics is a
language anyway yeah the same way we use
any other language I'm going to repeat
that 2+ 2 is 4 not because it's
necessarily true per se or in of itself
but because it's useful in my daily life
we consider it to be true because it's
useful yeah I mean that's a whole that's
a whole like Paradigm sh internal it has
its own internal consistency yes within
its own hermeneutic but the thing the
pro it doesn't have anything objectively
beyond itself
like there's nothing do you mean by me
because you have to understand math is
just symbols sure math is a symbolic
structure that was it's a language that
was created to understand the world and
we're trying to see if it corresponds it
has corresponded with which showcases
that the human mind is actually tied to
the
universe yeah which if you want to
really confuse an
atheist you want to make why does yeah
you got ask like why does why do your
brain of this little animal that evolved
from you know the
the the ancestor of an uh the cousin of
an ape right living on this little blue
ball in the middle of nowhere in this
massive Galaxy how how is it that we can
understand a black
hole yeah what what what's going on
there wasn't there this one essay called
like the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics in the Natural Sciences
doesn't that make sense though we live
in this same thing for the concept of
God the same thing that I use for the
the argument for my for for God's
existence or the rationality belief
God how is it that we live in such a
small planet with such small minds and
yet we are conceiving of something that
is not immediately apparent to
us at least like the world look okay and
this may this makes a lot the world
didn't have to have patterns and well
yeah not even we didn't have to be made
to understand it yeah but not even that
but think about it it's like why would
this small little planet if if we're all
just just you know Adams and this is all
just a natural coincidence and there's
no intelligence behind everything right
whatever why is it that the world or in
our minds have this conception of
intelligence beyond our natural plane of
existence right there's nothing here
that's pointing that out to us unless
it's already inbuilt or there's actually
some sort of reality behind that you
know what I'm saying like there's no re
there's nothing here that's telling me
God now of course Muslims believe in
signs but that coincides with our
because we also believe that we created
we see design because we're created to
see
design right but for a naturalist is
like where do you get the idea why are
we coming up with this idea in our minds
the whole thing with I I brought up the
whole thing about the fish and the fish
tank right I know everyone hates that
example for some reason because they
don't own fish but you know for me it's
like a fish doesn't understand anything
beyond its borders in the fish tank it's
like it's not going to be like
contemplating with his small little
brain you know whether or not there's a
bigger fish tank out there or like
there's a there's something Beyond its
its own immediate existence it only
knows what's in those
borders right that's its world that's
everything it's it's supposed to know or
can know about itself and about it and
about its reality but humans for some
strange reason despite being confined on
this little teeny planet in the middle
of
nowhere can understand things that are
light years Beyond
us what the hell is going
on MH that that shouldn't be possible it
is but
why and the question is not the answer
is not I don't know therefore God the
answer is God because there is no other
possibility do you see what I'm trying
to say like that's the most coherent
explanation right is an intelligence
that has given us
intelligence you know and that wants us
to know these
things right there's nothing else that
would make sense saying oh it's just big
Cosmic accident and we just happen to be
intelligent more than the actual
universe
itself you know there's no intelligence
out there it's only on this little teeny
blue plan in the middle of nowhere talk
about egotistical I love it when
atheists call us e egotistical because
we believe that God thinks we're special
it's like you don't you think you even
more special than that because you think
we're the only intelligent things in
this whole damn universe
like we live on this little blue planet
in the middle of nowhere you think that
oh that we're the only smart ones and
that the Universe was just randomly or
not even randomly but just just
naturally uh organized without any
intelligence whatsoever that we're more
intelligent than whatever made this
thing
really talk about
ego I'm happy that I'm a human otherwise
you know like I could have been born a
fish well you know but think about like
how much ego that takes that you think
that you're intelligence is superior to
whatever made this
universe and you have the audacity to
claim that theists are
arrogant we're not saying we're more
intelligent than the universe or
whatever made this universe we're saying
that there is something more intelligent
than us and that we're limited in our
conception of
reality atheists are the ones going
around go you're stupid because you
believe there's something that's smarter
than you out
there like
seriously so I don't know if that was
profound for me that that's signif that
was that was very profound no that was
pretty deep yeah like no what like for
me what was profound is that like when
you pointed out the pragmatist and you
pointed out basically people are are
pragmatist just naturally we are we just
don't have words I mean the pragmatists
are just trying to put words to the to
the natural human understanding of
themselves and the reality around them
because like you said no one empirically
proves every single thing that they
believe they were stupid
even the atheist they claim that only
fall imperical proof they don't they
don't because they wouldn't be able to
function they wouldn't be online every
day debating with theists if they
believe
that yeah they be they'd be so skeptical
they probably drive themselves to
Insanity right yeah like there's there's
too many things that you can't
emperically prove that you already
accept no no you look at even the things
that like we're talking about morals
again you can't empirically prove like
human rights no you can't yeah you can't
empirically prove human rights like it
you try to argue darwinian Evolution but
even then you can't that's not really
like we've evolved to cooperate even
that is like a stret whole morals all
our values our political structure
economic structures everything that we
basically value as human beings and I
mentioned this a lot in many lectures
90% of the things you believe in as a
person that makes you a human being
about belief about yourself about your
family about other people around you
about Society there's nothing scientific
or empirical about it at
all and yet the world works and yet you
as a person
work you know you function in the world
that you were
given but atheists never question they
never you know if if they that's why I
don't
believe and it sounds they hate when you
say this I don't believe atheists are
really atheists because they don't act
like that they act like theist who just
happen to remove one part of the
equation while keeping all of God's
attributes wa how so they remove God
while keeping his attributes in the
world yeah I know like how how are
atheists how do how are all closet
atheists just atheist because they still
believe in sorry how are closet atheist
theists even though they claim that they
don't believe in Transcendent values
they act as though those things
exist yeah they cannot do otherwise you
can't go you can't believe in human
rights and be like yeah I don't really
believe this is
true like that just doesn't make any
sense you can't just be like yeah you
know I don't I believe these are just
arbitrary constructs that we've designed
in order to you know yeah but most
people most people most atheists do
understand that they're arbitrary
Concepts they say that but they don't
behave like
that they behave their life is on the
line if they don't support these things
like H Society will not function will
not operate unless these things are
there human beings will all die out or
be destroyed Humanity itself will fall
to pieces if they don't support human
rights they will they will their lives
they will demean other people on the
basis that they don't follow those
things right that's you're acting like a
theist basically yeah they make Tu fear
of everyone who disagrees with them yeah
exactly we're basically Kar to them yeah
and that's the thing that you don't you
don't act like that if you think
something is
arbitrary no yeah you don't legit
atheist would be like if you
were you'd be like oh here's like a a
murderer and then here's like an
engineer Le they could say well I feel
that way because I'm just naturally
inclined to do so but I know for a fact
that it's not really what I should be
feeling and then they'll Analyze That
and they'll deconstruct it but they
don't act like they just don't they they
act like everyone else how you're
supposed to behave while posturing that
they don't believe in something when
they actually behave like they do but
then you can you can flip that around
and put that on Muslims as well that
like oh Muslims are supposed to behave
as like if they really were Muslims they
were supposed to behave as though
they're about to die at any single like
any second right they should be praying
all the time but yet they forget about
death right no our beliefs don't say
that our beliefs are just as much rooted
in the world as they are in in the in
the Hereafter I mean much of our
theology is centered around doing good
things in this world in order to get to
the
Hereafter I mean being yeah but why
don't why don't people act like that
though even Muslims they they spend most
of their time in free time or they spend
most I don't want I don't want to use
the formal term MAF because that's
that's has a more uh Sinister
connotation but you know they are
hypocrites in the loose sense and there
are many Muslims out there and there
Many religious people in general out
there that act hypocritical in terms of
what they believe and what they and how
they behave right what they claim to
believe and how they behave and that's
just that is normal that is normal for a
lot of people and that is a problem with
that individual and the what they're
experiencing
is um in many ways it showcases that
they don't believe in just one
thing yeah they believe in multiple
theories or multiple or have a mix of
Paradigm right their Paradigm is sort of
a hybrid because hypocrisy is not is not
simply like um hypocrisy is not simply
saying thing and doing another thing
it's thinking that you believe something
but in actuality is it you're trying to
convince yourself that you believe in
something but in actuality you know you
don't you know it's kind of like um
denial
self-denial you know there are a lot of
Muslims who try to rationalize
themselves as being Muslim while doing
things completely contrary to the Faith
by trying to basically make the the the
the Halal you know you have Muslims out
there who actually claim that drinking
is
halal or that eating pork is halal or
eating nonh halal food is
halal you know or saying it's not a big
deal don't judge me right because you
know it's between God and me well if you
really belied it was between you and God
you wouldn't do it because he's much
worse judged than anybody
else if you believe you you wouldn't do
it but couldn't they just couldn't
those struggling I'm
struggling then in many ways say that
they're holding on to that Faith like
yeah like what I'm confused at
is like because would couldn't you say
oh someone that's sinning they're just
low Iman they don't just necessarily
disbelieve no I'm not saying the
disbelieve I'm saying that hypocrisy
Even in our religion one can have
elements of hypocrisy without being a
disbeliever oh a you mean okay one can
fluctuate between certain things there
there levels of
hypocrisy and a prentist would say yes
you need to fix
that yeah okay but there's a point where
it's like like I said there are more
apparent forms where it's like okay you
claim you need to pray to be a Muslim
you claim to be a Muslim but then you
say you don't have to pray you yourself
like that's a
contradiction right or it showcases that
you're not really you don't really
believe as you say you're not who you
are right that's that's different from
like trying to pray and falling short
yeah falling short is like you're
struggling with yourself you're
experiencing anomalies and you get to as
PR say you have yet to work out your
issues okay like you're you're
struggling there's a battle going on
right between two alternative paradigms
your desires would would function as
another form of Paradigm yeah NS your NS
your desires would be what you're you're
fighting between the two you're holding
on to your Paradigm you're still hold
like it's like there's a battle going on
whereas another person just simply
claims with one on one hand and then
they act completely
different way that's that's not a pra to
say you don't actually believe that
thing you see what I'm trying to say
yeah so like what I mentioned about
atheists like they they most of them say
that morals don't have any real
objective value or meaning or purpose
and yet
they believe complete contrary to this
they act contrary to this this statement
these statements that they
claim like that makes no sense to me
yeah I don't the last question sorry I
don't believe anything without empirical
evidence yes you do what are you talking
about you know like like I said 90% of
the things you believe in don't have
empirical
evidence that's nonsense because you act
like because you act as though those
things that don't have empirical
evidence are true therefore real they're
real things yeah that's the thing like
morals you believe you act like those
things are are greater realities are
just as greater realities as your own
car and your house and the food you eat
don't sit here and tell me you
don't you evolved to be that way as a
human species well even then that's
still yeah but okay so then you got that
pragmatic could fire back and say if you
evolve to be like that then why don't
you act why don't you believe in
Conformity to
it why are you going against your
natural inclination
you're defying your evolutionary
development
why ah okay makes that's why these
evolutionary don't work on pragmatis
because we're just going to fire back
and say that's you see Alvin planica
actually developed which is funny
because he analytical philosopher he
doesn't really believe in pragmatism but
he developed a really beautiful argument
against
Evolution um which I don't necessarily
agree with because I think it could be
turned around a bit but I think it's
really interesting how he kind of flips
the script he says basically like you
can't really trust your beliefs to be
true because what is evolutionarily fit
is not necessarily
true oh down you see what I'm saying but
of course a pragmatist would respond and
say well it doesn't matter then because
you wouldn't know otherwise right right
yeah you'd have to follow that anyway
because you don't have any choice you
don't have Choice yeah so but for for
what he's arguing against is very
effective for just like I don't care
because I
have wait what's evolutionary is not
necessarily true what does that mean
because like you could develop an
evolutionary trait that helps you
survive without that that thing actually
being like you could develop a trait
that anytime you hear a certain
sound right like you'll develop a
reaction to run away from it even if
there's no op there's nothing there to
run away
from survive but it doesn't mean that
the thing is actually
there right right smell or a certain
well no well like I guess a good example
would be like your evolutionary trait
for like uh I don't know what's what's a
good example like procreation or uh yeah
just just your impulse right like why
aren't you why are you denying your
impulse of like sleeping with like I
don't know 10 women or something I don't
know denying your impulse well I mean so
the evolutionary trait would be like
okay so you feel aroused with a certain
sex right yeah um
so I guess you could say why are you
denying somebody could say well I've
heard Evolution or atheist say that rape
is very natural to me that makes no
sense um why not from their perspective
that makes sense well rap perspective it
makes because rape from their
perspective even though that guarantees
the most like the best way to quote
unquote procreate I guess you could say
it doesn't function in a way that would
help
Society raise families which are That's
essential to
human civilization which is why I think
nonsense when they say that but
um yeah I
mean even evolutionists themselves
people who believe in evolution they
tend to go to extremes and and say
things that they don't really comprehend
too
well uh but yeah so Al planica would
serly say something like okay so
everything that that evolves doesn't
necessarily lead to truth because it
doesn't need to just needs to lead lead
to
survivability right right pragmatis
would just argue well that doesn't
affect me because whatever is survive
whatever lead survivability is is what
we would consider true anyway
yeah do you understand that so like
everything that you consider to be true
is only true because it really just
helps you
survive the world survivability is just
one part of functioning like living is
one part of functioning the other part
of functioning is being able to go
through the world and understand it
organize your ideas appropriately
experience it well benefits you in terms
of your mental psychological physical
health Etc Etc it's a whole holistic way
of being I mean human beings don't just
live by surviving surviving is not just
the only thing humans do right we also
love right that's Beauty we we we
experience
War conflict yeah like love like why do
you like you can't
prove like is love like proving emotions
prag just wouldn't care they like why
why are you we're trying to prove
something what what is there to prove
empirically right if you were to operate
from that Paradigm yeah like
real like how do you empirically prove
that yeah priv say who cares yeah
say well proba wouldn't say who cares
but he say who cares about your method
because I experienced love so therefore
it's real well just not necessarily say
it's real it's therefore this is the
only way I can behave this the only way
I can act and believe right right okay
can't say with 100% certainty that it is
the
case in terms because I don't have full
knowledge of the subject but I have to
but I act as though I do because there's
no alternative there's nothing for me
else to to behave as like I love because
I am human I'm human because I
love there's nothing else there if you
tell me love isn't real then I'm going
to tell you that you're a [__] who
doesn't understand what it means to be
human right and then atheist that if is
say that they're empirical but still
believe in love that's that's
inconsistent I need empirical evidence
oh it's just all chemicals well I'm
sorry I don't experience
chemicals even just chemic how do you
know which chemicals respond to like you
can't really find the chemicals that
correspond it's like I don't experience
chemicals what isn't your experience
isn't your emotion the chemical no no it
isn't has meaning like the reason I
sacrifice myself for my wife isn't
because of
chemical there's more meaning my love
and if I start defining my love as a
chemical you as a human being will not
understand what I'm
saying
right like you can't function if you
define it as just like an Impulse yeah
like oh it's an Impulse that's why I'm
protecting you no that's not how people
function it's not how we talk to each
other yeah that makes sense do so I know
it sounds it's starting to sound
mystical but it's not it's just it's
that those things are left to the side
for the details but the primst basically
just says
this
holistically everything that works in
your favor to not only promote your
survival ability but promote your
survival but to promote your mental your
physical your psychological health and
that makes sense of the world around you
that helps you to explain
everything and and leaves you with less
confusion and leaves you with you know
more answers than questions that is the
belief that you need to subscribe to
okay that's the belief you need to
subscribe to and um and these can be
determined based on inner workability
and external workability so internal
workability is the internal coherence of
the subject or of the Paradigm so for
example of their internal consist
inconsistencies with regard to logic or
between other beliefs then of course the
Paradigm is there's something wrong
about it uh and the external uh
coherence is whether or not it can
absorb anomalies or explain anomalies
away or if it can or if it's the better
explanation out of an alternative that
is that you're approached with does that
make
sense
like it basically it has to be
consistent its inner it's its inner
belief system needs to be consistent
with uh with basically your coherence of
uh of what you experience and plus of
the claims it makes and then it needs to
be able to
explain like explain anomalies uh within
it without without breaking its system
now before we go on the next question if
you don't mind I just want to very
concisely remove this misconception of
pragmatism people say well what it means
by works is that anything that gets you
what you want within that given time I
was ask about this no that's not that's
not pragmatism because pragmatism
requires that you be consistent with
your own principles if you have to
violate your principles to get something
that you want then you've actually
destroyed the pragmatic aspect of your
own
beliefs you see especially you become a
hypocrite and hypocrisy what it's not
pragmatic yeah you become hypocrite yeah
so because hypocrisy is against is
pragmatism is opposed to
hypocrisy yeah 100% that makesense
that's not pragmatism unfortunately
groups
like right they are the on they Define
pragmatism in this way as
Hedonism and that is
wrong yeah that is wrong yeah so that's
not what can you explain why it's wrong
why is pragmatism because why is
pragmatism not Hedonism pragmatism is
not Hedonism because right because your
beliefs still need to manifest in your
in your action so if your principle if
you're compromising your your internal
principles that you believe that breaks
uh that breaks your pragmatic principle
because you're you're you're
contradicting what you're saying you
believed originally no but what if I
just believe Hedonism is just a way to
live then that wouldn't be no that that
doesn't invalidate pragmatism because
you just believe you believe in Hedonism
as a pragmatist
yes you believe in Hedonism as a
privatist okay so then if you're an
actual
hedonist action then you're then you're
then you're consistent right if if
you're like a if you're like a yeah if
you're a hedonist and you're a
pragmatist and you practice Hedonism
you're consistent but if you're like if
I'm a Muslim and I'm pragmatist and I
practice Hedonism there's like an
inconsistency that I need to resolve it
doesn't okay yeah that makes sense that
makes sense guys I got it yeah and then
if I talk to like I would if I talk to a
hedonist from a pragmatis perspective I
would I would actually question why what
is the pur like what is the what is the
Simplicity of his belief why Hedonism
like why is that what makes the his his
reality his Universe
coherent okay what is the significance
of of that belief that's what I would
ask now if he's if he's true to himself
you'll find that there are certain
values inherent within his actions that
are inconsistent with themselves yes
because because we believe right doesn't
really think too much about what they're
doing yeah and that's and that's because
we we're
right well you have to believe you're
right there's nothing wrong being right
that's another thing a lot of atheists
come across that they're very arrogant
in this way too and kind of stupid in
the same way when they say well you guys
act like you're always right about well
how else am I supposed to act yeah like
me believing in my thing implies that
I'm right yeah you want me to go around
going I don't know what I believe that's
not GNA help me what yeah you know and
they do too they just act leg go and say
no we're very open-minded no you're not
because you're acting like a jerk
they're not open-minded if they were
open-minded they would they would
consider each and every single
possibility yeah you have in other words
you have to be dogmatic about certain
things in order for you to even function
exactly everyone yeah exactly 100 per.
you have to have an opinion you have to
be you have to think you're right about
something make any sense yeah you you
you'll make some assumptions on what you
believe on what you believe already you
want to get into more detail read this
book what's it
called by William James by William James
the new name what's it called new name
for what for some old ways of thinking
some old ways of thinking his first
lectures on the subject matter it'll
give you a brief concise version of what
I've just talked about I hope I've
explained it efficiently but you know y
pragmatism pragmatism is just another
word for
fitra fitra is your intuition but
pragmatist is basically like how do you
how do you believe and function based on
that it's like your it's like your
pragmatism is like the combination of
your F and your
rationale something like that I don't
know is a pragmatist okay we'll stick
with
that that was pretty good you could try
to explain to me before I didn't really
get it uh I hope I know it sounds kind
of vague but reality it's very simple if
you really think about it in terms of
how you actually behave and act and the
whole issues with empiricism and
rationalism and all this other stuff
that's come up in in recent years the
past few hundred years actually is
really actually I think it's confusing
people more than anything because it's
making you narrow perspective when in
fact that's not how you actually
operate MH you know there are different
modes of existing and and interpreting
and perceiving things right it's not
only empir being empirical so from your
perspective do you believe that there is
no one objective
wait I think that there are such things
as facts and I think there is such thing
as truth but when you're talking about
whether or not one can perceive
something other than what they
experience and believe
no okay
well like
there's well you say perceive you do
mean experience as well yeah because you
look you can't jump out of your head
right like all you know is what you see
and and what you experience and what you
hear and what you feel and what you
think you know that's all you know you
don't know what everyone else
is only by what they tell you and how
they behave you can sort of deduce
certain things but you really only know
your own experiences and your own and
your own
perceptions right like my understanding
of fad is not who fad is it's my
perception F knows himself more than you
do yeah exactly and you know more than
he does yeah but I I can't I can't
experience knowing him more than he
knows himself you can't experience what
he's experiencing either yeah
exactly yeah you wan to go to the last
question yeah yeah let's go next this is
pretty crazy are you trying to write a
book yes I am okay what's what's this
book going to be
about lot of things right now I'm trying
to see if I can narrow it down but
basically I'm trying to
address the Muslim youth the Muslim in
general in terms of our thinking and and
seeing if I
can I it's a very um ambitious project
in which I'm trying to see if I can
reverse certain
things and trying
to bring Muslims into a different realm
of thinking where we can move forward
intellectually that's and I know that
sounds very ambitious and and and super
confident in myself but you know
something that I I have to do and I
don't know if I'll succeed or not but
you know that's something that I'm
trying to do right now and and I'm
developing a lot of um the arguments
that I've kind of expressed to you guys
and a lot of my own approaches the
subjects of ex-muslims and apostasy and
modern world liberalism Etc are all
going to be in this one book I don't
know what I've named I have some
tentative titles but um
titles I have to look at them
see uh I had one in particular that I
really liked and a lot of other people
thought it was a good idea and basically
it's um the book is gonna be about
Islamic futurism right it's not just
about atheism it's not just about it's
about everything I think that we're
dealing with right now and I'm going to
try to make it as concise as possible of
course you can't you know it's so much
to talk about at once and I may write
other articles and and more
detailed um books on or on the subject
matter later
Point
um but let's see where's I think I put
the title here I'm sorry towards a new
Andalusia no no no see the thing is my
whole thing is that I don't want to
actually oh yeah I don't want to bring
in the past that's the thing like I want
to use the past as a form of inspiration
but not as a means of of of um actually
getting there
um as or trying to copy that what
happened in the past because I don't
think that's possible and what I mean by
that is that we're experiencing things
that we're not experienced back then and
we're going to be experiencing things
that we're never experienced in the past
so how can we apply the same structures
and ways of thinking from the past to
our future and that's something that you
know I want to develop a new paradigm
which is addresses a lot of our concerns
and what we need to be doing and um I
guess and I mentioned this to you guys
earlier prior to this podcast basically
I want to develop a form of Islamic
futurism where I want Muslims to start
thinking about where can we
go where can we be where should we be
going and how can we
surpass our Rivals not how we can be
like them not how we can revive the past
and be like our ancestors no I don't
want Muslims to be like how do we return
to the Golden Age I want Muslims to be
like how can we make a new
one yeah um so you know and there's a
lot to do with that you know and and
it's still very tensive as well there
are a lot of details in my head that I
really haven't put to paper yet and I
really need
to but essentially um the whole idea is
that I want Muslims to start thinking
Beyond what we currently have at our
disposal here I want them to start
thinking in a way which puts them in the
future uh which places their children in
the future it's sort of
like um We complain so much about what's
going on right now and what we need to
do to fix right now and I think the the
actual Solutions are not focusing on
what's going on right now I think the
solutions are focusing on what is going
to
happen right what where how we can reach
a certain point
you know um we spend so much money
trying to put Band-Aids on things that
we're not thinking about developing
structures and infrastructure and and um
organizations and methods which which
can resolve things for the future which
can put us in a place in the future
which is not where we are right now
obviously which is probably the lowest
point that we've ever been in our
history that sounds all very vague
because it is uh I haven't really
organized my thoughts that much on this
subject I do know that I think I'm going
the right direction but you know um so
for example let me just give you one
that I thought about quite a bit the
whole issue with the
caliphate okay we lost the caliphate uh
oh uh oh that's fine I don't care talk
about this L we lost the unity among
Muslims the general political Unity
among Muslims it wasn't completely
unified in the past but it was more
unified than it is now we lost the
traditional cipate structure and as a
result of that we become disunified
now for a lot of Muslims traditional
Muslims out there they they keep wanting
the caliphate back right they want to
bring back that old structure they want
to bring back these things and and
reestablish Islam as this massive Empire
that you know that's ready to Take On
The World okay that's fine you want to
have that ideal here's my
ideal how about you put that as your
future Focus but let's move in a
pragmatic fashion towards that goal and
not think about it idealistically let's
not think about how the past structured
things let's not think about what's
going on right now how we can develop it
you know in accordance with our our
contemporary surrounding let's think
about getting to one particular goal
that can help us get to that goal
eventually right so a sort of gradualist
approach but one that's more um
realistic and one that can immediately
benefit this Uma uh for the future right
and so for example I've come up with an
idea that instead of going for this
traditional caliphate right let's think
about a new
paradigm uh and let's let's let's look
at something that is immediately
workable like an Islamic
Confederacy
okay between the Contemporary nation
states so we're still taking some things
from the present but what we're doing is
we're looking into the future in a way
where uh we can resolve a of our issues
and focus on things that are more
productive let's say right establishing
because establishing a caliphate right
now isn't gonna happen it's just not
gonna happen it's ridiculous to think
that way um and there's there's nothing
around in our immediate environment or
contemporary sense that is going to help
us get
there so Islamic futurists would think
okay since we're going for the long run
plan let's figure out the best way to
that path let's not establish it now
let's figure out what we can do now to
get to there
okay so for example I've thought about
an Islamic Confederacy between nation
states very similar to the EU but a
little bit different in structure in
terms of uh one that Contin you know
makes that still allows for Muslim
majority countries to remain autonomous
while simultaneously giving resources to
each other Etc and basically you know um
relieving ourselves of of current
burdens that we have don't they already
have that in like the Islamic
organization it doesn't
work so the OIC doesn't work
um function because the states aren't
really uh they're not tied to each other
in a legal sense in the way that that
would a spiritual metaphysical kind of
make it a consequence if they deviated
from that plan so for example if you
really wanted to have uh an organization
of Islamic cooperation they would all
share the same
currency they would all share the same
economic burdens they would all share
the same military
Powers right things like this okay right
now that's not happening so that's why
they're completely autonomous the OIC is
simply an organization that gets
together and
talks about stuff they have there's no
legal obligation to each other at all
they can violate their agreements at any
point in time without any
consequence right there's no contractual
all say well we're all Muslims so we're
all United no they're not they don't
care okay you know if if if if Iraq
wanted to go to war with Iran tomorrow
or sorry with Syria tomorrow or Syria
want to go to war with Saudi Arabia
tomorrow they could do it nobody would
care there's no contractual agreement or
consequence from either side you know
for like say if there were member states
and they all had this agreement and if
one of them violated it and all other
states would be obligated to go to war
with that state that's not going to
happen
right there's no feasible structure
right now that is gearing the Muslims
towards
unification likewise there's no feasible
structure right there's no structure
right now in the um that is allowing us
to be scientifically
productive I mean you have the
university system University system is
based what on
what what do you mean it's based
off it's based off of like Colonial
structure Western Paradigm right Western
paradigms right capitalist
systems why do you think going overseas
for what
reason but isn't that the same exact
Paradigm or that we had in or that
Muslims had initially what do you mean
that like they had universities in the
past as well like University of bdad
university we did have universities of
course we had universities what I'm
trying to say is all of our talent is
going overseas though why are they going
overseas
because it's better more advanc money
well for one they're
funded money yeah jobs right how many
rich people are in this
UMO there's a lot actually quite a bit
where is all that money
to um buying cheetahs and the doctors
ches all the Muslim doctor that's a good
point because even in America most of
the Muslims are what Engineers doctors
yes so they have right where's all that
money going I don't know
to their kids say to refugees houses
okay good thing we're giving a lot of
money to refugees we're giving a lot of
money to Palestinians we're giving a lot
of money to all these people we're ging
a lot of money here there there right
right what about the money to invest in
technology where's the Ellen
musk of the Muslim um where where are
these Muslim entrepreneurs developing
businesses and things
yeah is y y but isn't business only
going to come when you have like
stability no not necessarily Muslims in
the west are doing very well for
themselves yeah yeah I think I said I
think it's because Muslims don't think
big that's what I'm trying to say there
is a certain level of thinking in this
umah that is not looking at the future
yeah they're not thinking they're
small-minded that's the point I'm trying
to make we don't invest in the future
we're investing in
Band-Aids and we're investing in trying
to bring to revive a past that no longer
exists
I want to create a mentality all right
through this sort of movement
intellectual futurism where Muslims
completely invest in Things That No long
that don't exist yet but can and
will for an evident future where our
children or our children's children can
benefit most from these things I also
want to address things like career
choices like you
mentioned why are there so many Muslim
medical doctors and Engineers for God's
sake no offense I'm good at it I age I
agree
okay so what about my field I would like
to advance a movement or even maybe make
an organization where I start to uh
promote the idea that Muslims should be
Librarians now you're probably thinking
that's creepy that's weird why is that
why is that necessary why would you need
I think it's good why but think about a
lot of Muslims will ask me like what's
the point of that what's productive
about that yeah why do you about it what
if Muslims had all access to Major to
all access to information
around the world actually Google not
just through Google but actually
controlled the flow of
information you mean like a Muslim owned
Google okay so what was the most what
was the most prominent thing about the
early Muslim Community prior to the
advancement of
science prior to the advancement of
Science in the
Muslim huh was it knowledge we used have
we used to have crazy libraries we had
libraries afterwards yes but what did
the Muslims do prior to advancing
technology and science
num there was a movement that
happened during the OM
period no I don't know I everything
around
them we say that again they were
translating and collecting as much
information as
possible they were learning about
everything around them they were
modifying text they were making
commentaries on text essentially they
were they were functioning as librar
prior to even advancing a lot of these
things they were learning as much as
they could preserving information
Muslims are still credited to this day
for preserving the Greek tradition
why uh because we did because we did
right yes
yeah so libraries were or Librarians or
information Specialists you want to call
them were very were essential to the
Golden Age back then so they can be
essential now to a new one Muslims don't
like reading anymore I don't know if you
noticed that no they don't I think
people in general don't read no yeah but
Muslims in general we should be at the
Forefront of preserving information of
not even that but even uh free
expression lacking censorship and what I
mean by that is I'm not saying we should
be okay with blasphemy what I'm trying
to say is that Muslim before anyone else
we're preserving heretical
text we're
preserving you know other ideas that
were opposed to Islam because they
wanted to learn everything around them
that's how they were Su
successful in in in developing things
and also in incorporating other
societies into their into the the larger
poy and even conquering other
civilizations because they knew who they
were talking to and who they were
dealing with you got to know your enemy
we don't know anything now because we
don't even bother to research anything
about the world or to preserve the
knowledge that we have around
us right yeah you're right these are
abstract things I know these are very
vague things that I'm talking about what
about other professions not just the
engineer not just the the medicine the
uh the the the medical doctor what about
teachers why don't we promote being a
teacher in our Uma anymore we don't have
that we we always we put our lowest
Achievers in in the position of
scholarships yeah that's true why are we
failing because we have an
idea is it is it really that we're
looking towards the future or is because
we're focused more on the
present present um we want money we want
to be successful right now but if the
idea of Islamic futurism essentially is
to change that mentality to think about
what's going to happen in the future to
focus on the future and to say okay
let's invest because we're going to be
somewhere else at some point but Muslims
don't think about the future right now
they're not thinking they're not
investing in anything not even on AKA
there are so many Muslims out there who
are so focused on just making a
paycheck you know and and and they think
that that's okay that they actually
think that's part of their faith to do
that and I think that's a mentality that
has been pushed especially and I'm going
to be frank by Arab
Society well they have to make money
that's essentially materialism is is a
very big aspect of yeah well I also
think it's also it's probably we don't
have really we don't really have
anything else besides ourselves at this
current point right now is like we don't
have a like a c we don't have like a
centralized leadership we don't um
yeah but these things don't come out of
thin air we can't just establish them
and then everything will be work if you
don't change the
mentality gon care it's not GNA work
anyway everyone's out for themselves
everyone wants what's presently going to
work in the present
moment you know we're never going to get
ahead like I said the things that I'm
talking about are vague because I need
to work out the details more but the
point is I'm saying is that Muslims are
thinking too much about the past for the
present and nothing for the future
yeah yeah we think it's just going to
pop into our lap if we just work hard
enough and it's like no that's not going
to happen you have to work in a certain
way in a certain direction and right now
Muslims don't have anything that
guarantees our future in this world we
have nothing we literally have
nothing and that sounds really
pessimistic but it's what are you trying
to look for no I would an example of
Forward Thinking be like a Institute by
Daniel and
Institute those kind of things even that
is
reactionary steps in the right direction
in terms of relieving doubts but it's
about an immediate problem even I'll
even admit right now yaken Institute is
about immediate issues 100% no yeah uh I
want to focus on an organization way of
thinking methodology that focuses on
something a 100 years from
now you know uh one of the reasons the
Jews were so successful is because they
did just
that yeah that's you ever hear of a
blockchain he what do you Bitcoin
blockchain that's if if you want future
thinking Muslims need to be on
blockchain decentralized but imagine
imagine if we had centralized not a
centralized politics let's let's let's
think about that for later but imagine
if we had our
own okay let's start at the UDA there
are so many there are various schools in
madrasas around the world
right yes but they're not United at all
like Alazar and and Medina University
don't yeah in recent years no conformed
Islamic education there's no unified
Islamic
education I mean you can still get
Scholars from these various institutions
obviously that are very learned but why
is it that there's no unified Islamic
education system
the Vatican has
it no but that centralization you know
that's uh yeah but yeah dangerous having
that centralization is dangerous they
have a centralized Seminary no it's not
dangerous exactly what we had for a long
time yeah if you had your eaza from
certain Scholars you were considered a
scholar right but nowadays you don't
know where to
go mean you can go to Alazar sure but
then some people reject you go to do bun
the school or something but then
somebody over there will reject you
nobody's recognized officially there
needs to be an official Rec recognition
across the board from every country that
if you go here you will be
accepted right yeah there's no
centralized education system what else
are we
lacking I mean you just need a a milit
militarized like well is there a hub
industrialized militarized
compen is talking is there a hub in the
Muslim world right now for for the
advancement of technology and
science Saudi
Arabia yes King University petroleum uh
I'm trying to think honestly is there
any place in the world a Muslim can can
guarantee right now if they went there
they would they could Advance Science
and
Technology King
abdia yeah C is good King Abdullah
univiversity of Science and Technology
I've been there no I mean as as a hub
turkey as a
hub like nobody there's nobody in the
world that's going yeah I need or
non-muslims going I need to go there
they're gonna fund my research no no
there aren't that's the opposite there's
people going to the West now imagine
some rich Saudi shaks or Rich emirati
shaks funded an organization for all the
highest funded all of the highest
Advanced research in the world from all
do like they probably do I just probably
under research I I think I think I think
you're being a bit like overly
pessimistic no I am pessimistic because
it's true there's no experiment there's
no place right now in the Muslim world
that anyone can consider a hub for any
advancement of technology or science in
the world today and that that you
wouldn't go there and consider it a
research one University
even my point is we have a lot of money
and a lot of resources but we don't have
enough forward thinking but if we had
enough funding for these things do you
think these scientists would stay in
Germany or
Italy imagine if they got a bigger fund
from
Dubai yeah I think we're thinking quite
materialistically here we're thinking
part of is material no we're thinking
about like science like oh if we just
progress in science we just get more
money oh if we just certainly there
what's the benefit at the end of the day
what's the benefit of of doing all the
science who are we trying to impress try
better our own
civilization right but yeah I guess like
for example Muslims don't manufacture
their own
cars yeah but like what's the what's the
benefit of that at the end of the day we
don't manufacture anything we make oil
we make
plastic you're asking like what's the
benefit yeah what's the benefit like
we're not we're like not relying on
other other other Industries we are
completely dependent on everyone else
you're dependent you're not
self-sufficient we're good diplomats
then we don't even I mean we literally
at this point in our existence as a as a
society civilization I am I am the first
to I'm not the first to admit this and I
won't be the last and I'm not afraid to
admit this because we have a sever
serious problem we we are not we are no
longer the gem of so of the world and we
are we don't even we don't even give
anything in terms of as a society as a
whole yeah as individuals yes when we go
other places we give we have a lot of
talent a lot of money a lot of resources
but we're not putting it in the right
places
you see what I'm trying to say like
there's there's so much that as Muslims
can do that we're not
doing so what's the solution huh is is
the solution the book no the solution is
to change people's minds and mentality
obviously the book is for me is my way
of expressing uh these issues and and
hopefully moving people towards a
different way of thinking and you know
even if I don't convince if I convince
one person that might I'm hoping that'll
be enough
you know but it's the same thing with
like um and I don't and I want to be
clear that I don't put myself on the
same level as any of these people but
you know when Al gazali wrote his books
what do you think he was
expecting he was just trying to help
people through his own experiences and
trying to understand the world around
him he was trying to refute these
specific philosophers because he felt
the UMO was in danger and he wanted to
advance things he wanted to move things
forward like anyone else writes
books you know they want to put their
ideas out there hoping that something
will catch something will bite so that
they can hopefully change the world for
the better in some way and that's what I
want to do is my contribution and you
know if I end up not seeing it in my
lifetime May if I die and it happens
after that that'll be fine but point is
I have to do it I feel obligated to do
so it's my oral Moral Moral Moral
obligation to do it because I need
to manifest my ideas for the betterment
of other
people and it also selfish in some way
as well because I personally want to
benefit from it I personally want to see
these things happen
MH so I'm tired of being in in a in a
civilization that is being stepped on
every
day I'm tired of it but unlike the idiot
terrorist who's gonna go out there and
blow himself up I'm trying to I'm
looking to the long run because that's
also part of the problem with terrorists
today one of the reasons that they are
that they have little value for life is
because they're not thinking about the
future yeah they only think about right
now
all right yeah that makes no I I agree
with that I think I I think just Muslims
having their own just by creating your
own your own platform your own spaces
and you're you're talking about these
ideas that's like that's already like
kind of a bit of a a bit of a shift
because now you're gonna move people to
start thinking about these things well I
don't know what's but you know it's what
I have to do and say if I write this
book and maybe nobody believes it or
maybe nobody follows it but then one day
maybe some somebody who's better than me
picks it up and finds something in
they're worth
using and they they write a book that's
much better than
mine and that ends up doing something
all ideas are synthetic at the end of
the day yeah come every major
philosopher every major thinker that
you've ever encountered in in your
readings or your
life always got something from somebody
else in some way they're influenced
so yeah solid um wrap up I think that
covers everything F where
uh
uh no that's pretty good I think we like
I it was pretty in depth we covered a
lot of stuff that I wasn't expecting
which was good for me uh where where can
people reach
you I I travel you know like like online
and stuff on
um well get get on the derkastan Discord
for all our listeners yeah not everyone
has Discord though but like I mean this
this sounds kind of you know negative as
well but recently I've I've kind of sort
of distance myself a lot
from the whole scene uh I do comment
from time to time but I'm trying to
focus a lot on myself and kind of like
writing articles and things right now in
the book because I eventually kind of
want to get out of this this Arena of
that's persisting right now um and a lot
of it has to do with my own personal
struggles but you know um I'm still on
Facebook I'm still Discord a little bit
on YouTube you can find my channels
there and stuff and I'm still going to
be making videos for a little bit of
time but eventually you know I just want
to kind of live a quiet
existence uh because
what a lot of people don't understand
and and I think they don't realize is
that for people who do this who who
always in conflict with other people in
terms of their ideas and spirituality
and things and we're constantly arguing
with people it really drains you and it
hurts you a lot
actually and it's just gotten to a point
with me you know I've since ever since I
started ever since I converted to Islam
I've been doing this for 11 years
straight
Non-Stop and it's just gotten to a point
where like I feel
drained like I just need to take a
break um and I don't know if I'm coming
back or not but you know for the time
being I'm going to put everything I got
into it and
hopefully one day I'll I'll be
reinvigorated and I I'll have the
motivation again but you should take on
students what you should take on
students you should have like you should
become a mentor at I don't know if I
don't think I'm worthy of that that's
the thing I'm just you know for me it's
it's all it's always been a a loner
thing for me it's like I've always been
alone and I've always been part of
organizations to help not to be a
singular identity you know
um I don't know where I'm going to be
going the future and I'm sorry to end on
this sort of this sort of like very uh
kind of sad wait how how how old are you
you're you can't be more than 40 I'm 34
34 yeah you're still young still very
very very young you're old because of
all this and um you know it gets to you
after while his son never got his
mission until the age of 40 right yeah
you know the thing is maybe I don't have
any reason to complain but the point
that I'm trying to make is
that um it's it is hard work it's hard
on the spirit it's hard it's hard on the
your emotions it's hard on your
psychology it's it's hard on your it's
hard on everything and yeah it's hard on
finances too even yeah it's hard on
finances you know and when you struggle
to do these things every
day and you do your best and yet you
know you see islamophobe who who get on
a video for like 5 seconds and say I
don't like Islam and they get like
100,000 people supporting
them in a few minutes you know it's like
and you're sitting here and you're
struggling for years just to reach
people like one person you know
it's
yeah and uh it's something that I've
expressed to you you know before in
person and stuff and I'm just trying to
tell let people know the reason I'm
saying this is that don't take things
for granted don't take other people's
efforts for granted and you know if you
can support something even if you don't
support that person do your own best to
to spread a message so that you can
relieve the burden off those individuals
because there are so many times that I I
every day I I get approached by people
asking me questions and asking me to do
things but
then in the same way when I ask them to
do things they don't want
to or they're not willing to or they
think they're incapable or they don't
want to invest the time or the energy
you know well what do you mean by that
they want to put everything on one
person like can you give an example of
maybe an incident like this well I mean
just several occasions it's just that
they expect more from you than than
they're willing to give themselves they
want to say that dawa is an obligation
and it is in many respects but then they
want to put all their their hopes and
everything into one individual or only
certain amount of people while they
themselves still live their normal lives
quiet and away from all of these
things and if you're not willing to
support these efforts if you're not
willing to put in as much effort as the
people trying you know putting
themselves on the front lines don't
expect them to take on the burden for
that
long um because even the companions of
the Prophet PE people on him tried to
share his
burdens they didn't just sit back while
he did all the work and then you know
wave their Flags around in support in
the background yeah they fought with him
they died alongside him so part of this
the problem with this um and part of the
reasons I wanted to sort of also look in
uh sort of promote this Islamic futurism
is
because you you you get what you give
and if you're not willing to give and to
invest your time and your emotions and
your own intellect into these projects
into the da of others when they're
trying to go on the front lines if
they're waving the sword out and they're
going let's go into battle and there's
nobody behind them don't expect
success so what what should people do
then
well they need to start supporting these
these sort of projects more like you
know like
your everywhere else they need to start
spreading the message markeing
themselves unifying us unifying together
under one Banner for for one um
goal we need to stop being petty and
stop being lazy and stop thinking only
about ourselves and our immediate
experiences and and and and goals we
need to start thinking for the future
and you know you have a lot of Muslims
online who keep complaining about our
youth leaving the religion complaining
about this complaining about that but
what have you seen people
do yeah they haven't done anything do is
complain I've seen people complain about
yakin ISU oh they're not doing it right
they're not doing it right they're not
doing this they're not doing that what
are they doing watching you know cricket
games and etal series or whatever and
you know sharing memes online about
stupid things which is fine to some
degree but if that's all you're going to
do while you're critiquing and and
complaining all day then what's going to
happen so sorry to leave on a sad note
pessimistic note but my point is like
you know Muslims need to change their
mindset don't expect so much from the
people who are trying to do stuff like
you guys and myself and everyone else
and support everyone as best as you can
doesn't have to be financially even even
like just leaving a good comment or
sending a nice message me that helps me
because there are days where like I'm so
down the dumps and just seeing a comment
from somebody that I've never met saying
that your work has helped me or helped
somebody else that makes me keep
going yeah no 100% I I even feel that as
well like I feel very very happy when
when people give me like a thumbs up or
like on a video or like leave a really
nice comment yeah that keeps me going as
well or if someone messages me out
personally even that's I get on top of
the world for that day and more Muslims
see Muslims today seem more concerned
about Nicki Minaj than they do
about yeah it's it's unfortunate it's
annoying
so yeah and yo usoda puts in like maybe
100 times more effort than me and Amar
do with uh with everything so yeah 100%
I believe your content you're you're
also Del your content along with Daniels
I actually think it's quite important
because you you critique liberalism uh
in their own language per se and you're
you these guys they write like like
properly academic articles too and get
it published whereas like we just make
podcasts and we just talk about stuff no
podcasts are important you mean you're
creating a platform for people to speak
when we don't have platforms today I me
we have to create our own platforms
because nobody else is giving us one
yeah I this is this is integral you know
like you guys and boys in the cave and
all them they're doing as best as they
can to give us voices that when we you
know when we're shouting from the abyss
nobody wants to pick us up you know you
guys are are are going down there and
picking us up for them trying to make a
fair platform especially online That's
essential the problem is whether the
Muslims are willing to support those
efforts because we have a lot of Muslims
today like I said they complain they
know there are problems but they refuse
to do anything like they want everything
to fall into their
lap and I'm sorry if that's not like I'm
bashing this Uma but you need to slap
people around sometimes to wake them up
and it's time for for these Muslims to
wake up before it's too late because
we're getting to a point now where it's
like either you change the way you think
or everything around you you see is
going to get worse and it is getting
worse getting worse every
day you also another difference I just
want to let the listeners know that Al
he's put his entire like his his
livelihood in this right he's put his
entire career in this as well
okay like he's had to uh at one point
you've even had to like change what
you're studying in order to like just
keep up with finances right yeah I did
um yeah so go guys just I'm gonna say
straight up go support his patreon no
you don't have to my my point but my
point is you know just having that
support being able to get our message
out that would be sufficient for me yeah
you know if I could if I if my if my
content could rival the popular
islamophobes online I'd be happy but
right now I have you know alhamdulillah
I have enough support where I can say
that there are Muslims out there who
care like you know having 10,000
followers on Facebook is a decent thing
you know it's not it's not something to
to scoff at or to sit here and be like
oh you know I I feel so
whatever but why is it that there are
fewer Muslims willing to support the
work that we're trying to do to combat
islamophobia and you know and all this
nonsense out there and there are so many
more people willing to support those
hateful people those hateful individuals
why is it that you know an idiot a
literal like a literal idiot somebody
with below average intelligence with no
formal education can have a 100,000
something
followers on a social media platform and
spread their message to the point where
they're getting the attention of people
that don't even deserve they don't even
have the right to be talking
to and yet people who have struggled to
study and have sacrificed so much not
myself particularly but like a lot of
other people who are actually doing real
researching and trying to spread good
content put all their time and energy
can barely get you
know a few hundred views or 5,000 or
10,000 people supporting their work and
spreading it around you can't you can't
you can't battle these bad ideas this
way where are the Muslims where are they
that's what I'm asking where are
they there are more of us than there are
of these
idiots where are
you that's a good question watching
Cricket man watching
Cricket you don't want this Uma to die
but you are letting it
die where are you that's all I'm trying
to say and you know it's it gets
frustrating and I'm tired of it I'm
really tired of it I've almost given up
completely on everyone it there's there
are days where I just want to drop
everything and just like screw it you
guys kill yourselves off I'm gonna go
enjoy my life because honestly it's hard
to put so much emotion and time into
other people when they don't care about
themselves yeah I'm sorry I I sound
really mean but I that's how I really
feel and I'm sorry but that's just how I
feel and I don't know how else to feel
right now so that's
fine I think I think you should keep
going uh we got you on the support we'll
uh we'll spread the message you know
after 11 years straight time no like you
you can you can do what you need to do
uh if if you need to take a break but
just don't like don't disappear okay
yeah I mean that's that's what people
keep telling me but it's like don't
disappear you can yeah keep it keep it
on the low this is how I feel this is
like this is literally what my heart
right now this is like how I feel like
every day it my my belief in this like
apathy of wanting to be apathetic
increases because I'm not seeing people
coming to the stage going okay like
here's we need to start doing this we
need to fix this let's do this let's do
that there are very there are very few
and it just it boggles my mind that
there are so many people complaining but
not willing so many Muslims complaining
and wondering what's going on in the
world but they don't want to do
anything I don't I don't get it I don't
I do but I don't and I that's why I want
to write this book because I'm hoping to
God that it'll plant some
seed yeah in
will so so okay should we wrap up yeah
and I apologize for any vulgar words
that I use Etc I don't mean to be like
that I'm just being blunt good it's good
irritated so I apolog yeah you can be
real with us it's cool
okay
okay it's been a pleasure having you on
the show and we hope for the best for
you in the future and a and we ask Allah
to make things easy for you and we ask
uh
we ask the viewers as well toh make
things easy for us and share share our
content and
like pay us I'm SC uh as well um and
send us words of
encouragement mean mean mean and then
for you guys who are you guys are not
Allah so like just just do what I say
okay take care
guys